[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby here we are it's
Wednesday ladies and gentlemen and uh we
you wanna where are you gonna be this
week 's real quick I'm a member for a
funeral uh may I leave today buddy
we're both in Black for that reason oh
that's right yes we are for Grandma
who's 96. 98 passed away at 98. 98 years
old that's a great run that funeral
should be a celebration thank you so
here's the thing I was uh talking to my
dad I'm like hey do I have to wear black
because I have this real sick like dark
green suit like do I have to wear black
and he's like uh I think so I'm like but
let me I looked it up and so if it's
like a celebrate you should wear a dark
color yeah unless it's a celebration
then you can wear fun stuff 100 so I
told my dad I'm like we're celebrating
she's 98. I said Dad that's his mom
that's his mom I said Dad the thing that
sucks is she died right around the same
time the Queen of England did okay so
she got overshadowed this a little bit
at 98 a little bit now now I think a
green suit is not only appropriate but
but mandatory and my Grandma knows I'll
Flex on the fan she knows I'm gonna have
to flex on the phone correct I can't
come like Regular Joe McGee let me ask
you something I'm gonna Flex on them a
man can't work 20 4 7 forever if a man
can't grind his whole life and then show
up in a green suit he paid for with his
hard-earned money that was tailored to
his hard hard-earned body yeah bro you
know what I'm saying you don't think my
grandma would appreciate that thank you
you don't think she's expecting the [ __ ]
boy he thank you what up grandma what up
now here's the problem they'll be here's
a prom yeah there's a little bit of a
prom did a food truck yesterday with a
gentleman named Chris Barnett if you
know him uh they call him Beast Boy he's
300 pounds he can do a back flip and do
all this stuff I know Chris Barnett I've
watched him many times kind of a
Taekwondo guy in a way yeah he's
Taekwondo guy very athletic buy my
favorite food truck every such a sweet
dude is he yeah his fiance uh passed
away during his Camp what dude what I
was crying it was insane he was two
little boys what is one girl one boy
what happened but his story is amazing
so anyway so the truck was a uh a fish
truck you know I like salmon whatever
right shrimp sure
homeboy here or just uh Chris orders the
fried shrimp type move and then I go oh
I'll have the white fish with uh rice
and I'll do a side of the Ahi Tuna you
guys want to have dahi tuna and I go
I'll probably better you only Ahi too
out of a food truck making a slight joke
right the guy goes yeah probably a good
idea and all of a sudden he goes you
know what we do have the Ahi I'm like
toss it in there I I die and my buddy
George bro my [ __ ] is like a Russian
cannon it is Bombs over here I saw you I
went some things out with you I go you
all right oh dude yeah I've been
guzzling Pepto-Bismol yeah so I get raw
tuna dude out of the truck truck it's
not their fault [ __ ] up too hot it's
just not it's not what they do no and
then I asked Chris I text him hey man uh
are you are you having any issues from
the food that you ate I'm gonna show you
it's nah man that's why we're at the
fried [ __ ] I'm like there it is smart
man now he uh he is a guy who if you saw
him with his shirt off you would go uh
whatever I'm gonna fight that guy and
then he would beat the [ __ ] Bridge he
can dance his ass off he would do just
such a [ __ ] face just such a sweet
fun dude yeah like you know Mark takes
all the pictures and behind the guys
take all the behind the scene pictures
there's not one picture where he's not
laughing I know he's just such and then
when he's like even his attitude when I
brought up his fiancee passing away
which I was like I'm just curious I'm
not journalist we don't have to talk
about this if you don't want to let's
move on something else he's like no I'll
talk about it and he he knows it from a
t like she had uh water on her brain her
brain was swelling and just came out of
nowhere she's having seizures and it was
horrible Jesus yeah she passed away
quick he is he fighting Joel Romero or
is he or did he already fight you out
Romero because I would love to see that
fight no that I think that was a meme
right right I thought he was yeah so no
I saw that okay I thought Chris Brown
we've ruined the fun time about Chris
was in Bellator no no no he's new to UFC
though Chris Barnett he has uh four
three or four fights his last fight was
like fight of the did not know that yeah
yeah and then he missed weight at 265.
what yeah oh he's that big he's three on
him oh he's he said he was trying 280
but he was talking about like and this
adds my conspiracy that Daniel was so
mad about he goes the doctor came up to
me goes you're a pound half over and
he's like oh I'll I'll take a [ __ ] and
cut a pound and half on me can use now
your heart rate's way too high your
blood pressure is like no I'm fine dude
pound and a half I weigh 280 pounds this
is easy he's like no no I'm a doctor I
know what we're doing here I'm like oh
dude and he's five nine he's small dude
he's like five nine five eight yeah what
bring up bring up my Instagram there's a
picture of me and him good Lord he said
he said five eight on a good day he he
goes the UFC let's be at five nine but
that's hilarious yeah that's a very wide
fella
um we should probably get on so athletic
yeah ridiculously athletic yeah it's the
one I feel like he's the kind of guy
that if he actually was governor if you
wait there he is
if he was a certain amount of seat now
right there now I I look at that guy and
in a million years I would never think
he's a killer and he's a killer stupid
athletic stupid athletically was really
good at football I bet uh I've seen him
like he's a Savage now so athletic he's
gonna be the first uh UFC fighter
sponsor by thick wood if he was in
really good shape
I mean in other words if he had like the
body fat that I do would he be could he
fight a 205 or is his frame just too
thick I I I don't know it's just not he
didn't care I don't know he has so much
success like he has over 35. his first
fight in the UC was against Ben Romford
he does he yeah sure eight day notice oh
my God but you I was telling like you
can when he fought Ben Rothwell you lick
his demeanor because I'm telling you
dude I've been doing food truck what
four or five years favorite guest I've
ever had just his energy and he's so
happy and positive wow dude it brought
me into tears when he's talking about
his wife I was like dude sure I can't
believe that your wife passed away and
you're this like how just mentally
strong you are and how happy you're
about life and he's just such a good
dude and then he was saying like yo you
if you watch his last three five years
he's walk out he's dancing he dance he
dances he's eating dance dance yeah his
first fight against Ben roethl eight day
notice he's not dancing his heads down
and he's like yeah man it was a short
notice I was worried about everything
he's like it wasn't good
how did he do he lost yeah I mean first
fight you see if I'm Ben wrong that's a
whole different thing I had a very
interesting experience speaking of
inspiration and positive attitude just
wrap that up the whole thing with this
with that food truck I just don't want
to [ __ ] my pants that my grandma's
feeling
I don't know what to do oh well people
say take shots of whiskey I did it this
morning no I did a big shot of it listen
to me my girl's like oh you're an
alcoholic he's like wrong listen
diarrhea listen
hey shhh
I'm Gonna Get You we're going to start
you with a small one there's a series
and we start small work our way up and
by the time you're at the funeral you're
wearing secretly because you don't want
to be 18 gauge you're you're wearing the
18 games yeah I think you're wearing the
18 gauge you know what it is it's a
hockey puck so just give me a hockey
puck it's pointy but then we're gonna
mushroom out so it it's kind of a big
old mushroom upside down there you go
and we're gonna go with the 18 gauge
right there now I want I want you in
Crystal I want you in Crystal I want you
to wear a crystal butt plug nope I know
it's gonna be a [ __ ] I'm going to help
you with this no I'm gonna tell you a
Calgary flame hockey puck out of the
house and just Ram it up my [ __ ] that
is hard to get out
I'm gonna need you with the 12 gauge I'm
gonna help you with that I need you to
pick a spot on the wall and trust me and
I'm going to push that thing slowly
right in your [ __ ] because you're my
friend I don't want the clear one though
all this stuff I don't either but we
have to and I don't either that's all
you got in your bag in your car that's
all I got how you have them I don't know
either do I that's all you got I have
them for me I have them for for
discipline but for you you have them for
maintenance I can't be [ __ ] at my
grandma's funeral no you can't read
about it no so let's get that right
today Bubba I need you in that butt plug
and Pepto-Bismol doesn't do a lot no
I had uh so I had a wrestling match
yesterday
and I got punched in the face
why all right
I'm doing my my uh my next best of was
with a guy named Zion Clark now
I don't know if you know Zion Clark but
Zion Clark is getting ready for his
first professional MMA fight that'd be
Zion Clark Zion Clark was born with a
very rare spinal condition he has no
lower body he has no lower body he has
for the guys for the fans only listening
he has no lower body literally the
pictures we're looking at looks like
he's in quicksand yes like if you looked
at him it's one thing to have no legs
Zion Clark doesn't have hips Zion Clark
doesn't even have really a stomach his
body begins at sort of like his lower
ribs does he have a digestive system I
don't know I didn't get into that yes
none of these questions I didn't want to
ask those questions because
um groundbreaking questions he has the
world record listen to this guy now he
grew up in foster his mother he almost
dies on the table as a baby his mother
gives him up for for adoption she can't
handle it he he because he was going to
die so they they put this little boy in
foster care he grows up in foster care
his whole life
but what happens is when he's three
years old he's in church and he starts
playing the drums well sir he plays
seven instruments pretty fluently piano
drums on another level I was listening
to it he's also jacked yeah he's jacked
he then wrestled decided to wrestle and
lost
200 matches the first match he won was
in high school as a junior I was like
wait did you just get used to being a
loser and he said no I didn't and when I
won that that taste of Victory so now
he's getting ready for his thing and I'm
holding mitts for him okay
and then I decide to kind of grab them
you know to grab them now while you have
the method and you just you just yeah
and then I and then I he kind of he kind
of instinctually I throw two shots at
him and he instinctively moves his head
moves his head and does this thing where
he pivots off his hands now he runs
faster than anybody in the world on his
hands well I have a video of it fastest
runner in the world on his hands I'm not
even trying to be a dick in any faster
yeah
what's the pool look like that he's
competing against is there a is it a
deep pool with people no maybe MMA just
in general just in the world there's a
lot of people who walk in their hands
like is there a lot of competitions
well probably not but here's the other
question you can um you can bear a crawl
too and he'll be yeah anybody could
compete some people I think he runs 13
miles an hour on his hands it's
ridiculous yeah it's fast now here's the
other yeah
when you're holding myths and you're um
like you said you're throwing punches
yes I'm not making fun of this man in
any faster goddamn you know Legend yeah
are you on your knees I'm on my knees
you're not standing up no no otherwise I
was like yeah what are we doing but when
I wrestled him on your knees yeah he's a
[ __ ] it's as close to a human
backpack we talk about Damian being him
backpack that's what he is you're not
sitting out and getting away from him
when he wraps those arms around you it's
no I got choked out I could I was like
you know your naked joke too yeah it was
a disaster now did he pin you
it wasn't you know I'm sure pinning he's
done he wrestled you know his whole life
I'm saying you he just got you back when
you've been walking on your hands your
whole life your arms and hands and grip
your tendon strength is other worlds oh
your body's gonna dab it's other world
dude his dick beaters I bet he has to be
careful though oh my God I kept grabbing
his hand I was like what the [ __ ] big
hands yes and and I bet they spread out
he's 95 pounds and that's just that much
of his body he was born with so if he
was if he had a normal sort of if he was
born with legs and everything else he'd
be 210 pounds you've seen the good
looking guy you've seen the Collegiate
wrestler who dominates right one leg
it's not even with one leg I don't think
there's there's one with no legs well he
doesn't have he has he has a guy up and
stuff like that that guy with one leg he
was crazy because because the people you
know you know how ridiculous is society
yeah they're like well it's not oh wow
like it's not fair man he should be at a
higher weight class if he had legs it's
like but he doesn't so but that's what
he weighs like I know but how much
weight would he have he has such an
advantage he's so strong because he
should be at heavy weight without it
yeah you don't have legs we don't even
have a hand I think I don't know
people like this and I said I said to
Zion I said here's my problem
you know you make me feel like a piece a
lazy piece of [ __ ] you make me feel like
the biggest [ __ ] in the world this guy
this guy has no excuses how old is he be
he's 24. oh well and handsome too hey
really good looking guy and positive
like a person but not only positive like
he's got an attitude he's like
you know it's just like the glass is
always half full yeah man not a joke he
he was really inspiring but it was also
just he's funny and we had a great time
he's just he's jacked you know God I'd
love to see him [ __ ] you up you don't
get more Jack well you will because I
have a video I mean I really wanna I
wish I was his coach well he made a
mistake and hit me in the jaw
and he kind of pulled last second with
bare Knuckles yeah without with uh MMA
gloves oh that hurts so bad oh it hurts
so bad I haven't been hitting the head
God if he knocked you out [ __ ] it I
got flash knocked out yeah yeah and I
was like oh boy so you just mopped the
floor with you yeah he goes sorry sorry
he mopped the floor yeah he mocked the
floor he was like this if he gets behind
you
you're he's he's gonna wrap those arms
around your neck and you're you're gonna
have what's inspiring dude yes so I
assume can't procreate right I don't
know I didn't get into that we asked
really good
how he spoke to himself I wanted to know
what he would say to himself what he
does say to himself when it feels like
it's too much when it feels like you
know his parents abandoned him he was
adopted he had no one but he has this
really tight circle of friends that suck
up for him in school so I assume he uh
he got adopted he got adopted by a black
family white family a black woman who's
incredibly positive yeah and like kind
of religious that's half the battle
there you because if you're a kid and
you're dealt those cards which might be
the worst dealt hand I've ever heard of
I wear legs and no your family gives up
on you yeah but then you're adopted by
this [ __ ] angel of a woman an angel
just positive and doesn't doesn't
view you as a handicap or view you as
having some disadvantage so he had that
perspective and I would be willing to
bet she's the main reason for Success
well here's kind of what's [ __ ]
amazing about this guy I swear to God as
you talk to him like I was spending time
with him you're gonna think I'm like
being dramatic you forget you actually
forget that he has this insane this
insane condition because I don't know
he's got that energy that Force you know
now you might want to watch me bear
crawl and try to have a race with him so
the race was you biercon now could you
crab walk yeah I could crab walk and He
Still Smoked Joe well
you know let me see this Jim it's a
little astonishing
and so we're going to do a bear crawl
I'm gonna race Zion
to the dog pound sign right there yeah
we're a dog pound
uh race to me race to me his reach is
6'5
yeah I'm curious how big he would be
so his reach is six foot five yeah yeah
he's big
yeah I'm actually [ __ ] strong feel
like you're on the bench [ __ ] crazy
crazy
well there he goes oh well you're moving
so slow right well I'm a piece I mean
I'm an old you know what that is
disrespectful you barely [ __ ] went
[ __ ] I tried my hardest that's not
you there's no way that's your hardest
your back stiff go back I mean that's
that's if I'm Zion that's insult I don't
practice [ __ ] bear walking bro bear
crawling is tough like I think it's not
saying I practice but he's speeding It
Anyway let's just analyze watch how fast
is Brian but like
yeah I see your short steps yeah
you know what it was though I had gotten
hit in the head you're a little out of
it and I've gotten choked out and I I
was feeling shitty so maybe that's what
it is I don't know if I do that much
better that looks really lame though
because I didn't have it that was shitty
shoes and I didn't have good uh and
you're going and also you're
coordinating it's like how what is the
most efficient way I don't practice bear
crawling
yeah yeah he's got some speed
yeah let's get lunch after no because he
had to go train for his MMA fight and
his MMA fight I assume he's fighting uh
uh uh well he's fighting somebody who's
in his way class would be 120 you know
like oh my God yeah what poor 120
pounder when he gets a hold of him yeah
it's it's uh
wait now he's lucky it's not
K1 Japanese rules we can kick yeah yeah
well that's so you're not allowed to
kick so for when you fight Zion you
can't kick in the face you can kick his
body though you can kick the [ __ ] out of
his body we could also uh kick his arms
you can do all that [ __ ] now here's the
thing he's gonna grab your legs he's got
a lot of experience in absorbing that
shot and grabbing legs he trains down
with Rampage and all those guys down in
uh yeah down in Long Beach yeah body
shop I think the body shop yeah so
um you know yeah he punches
yeah yeah ramp base doesn't a lot of
those guys don't take it that easy he
probably likes that though yeah because
he doesn't want to be treated different
yeah he's what a [ __ ] badass goddamn
it was wild yeah I assume he's training
yeah just that's gonna be the thing
people are gonna try and kick his elbows
and arms and [ __ ] so you know what he
told me he told me though he hates like
when I did the interview I had to ask
him questions he hadn't been asked
before because I've watched everything
he's done and he was like it you know
for him it's like [ __ ] thank you for
asking me these questions that are not
Orthodox because the one thing he gets
so tired of is the same [ __ ] question
over and over where do you find your
inspiration
after a while it's the same you're not
getting anything it's like we get it he
wants to talk about like how do you talk
to yourself when you when you feel
hopeless or how you know how where does
religion play a factor in Iran after a
while you you start answering the same
questions and he had this this I'm just
so curious about reproducting like
having sex
digestive system I don't want to ask him
those questions because I don't I didn't
feel like that was available to me and I
I you don't feel the vibe with them yeah
I feel like those things are I wasn't
gonna ask Chris about his uh like before
I Came in Like Mike and uh Mike the head
of Mike Neal the head of thick was hey
just so you where his wife passed away I
know I know dude I know this yeah I can
lead with that no [ __ ] no but then as we
got going we had such a good vibes we're
friends yeah and I was like can I like
your fiance yeah I feel it's okay
he was like it helps me to heal as I
talk about it he's like because it
brings awareness because it went zero to
100. yeah she had a seizure and the next
day you know we're in the hospital and
then my kids are saying goodbye I was
like ah I don't know for me like do you
just does talking for you help
um does it does it neutral yeah talking
things out big time yeah it's the right
people you know that's right people yeah
big time big time yeah yeah I just I
feel like I like like part of what I was
writing about with my special is I just
guys don't have anybody to talk to
a lot of times you know I mean that's on
the guide too right like it's on the guy
to keep up with friends yeah man I mean
listen a lot of people fall off
especially if you're not in the same
race you know like
I don't talk to my friends as much when
I played football with because we're not
we're not we don't have the same say
when you're feeling a little bit like
depressed or sad I have some I have some
friends I mean you yeah [ __ ] you know
I got [ __ ] you know Todd Feldman mark
my brother you know I'm really not my
brother how long has Ben been it's not
like that man guys Henderson brother my
brother he's not he's not open like that
just like uh you'll figure it out yeah
thank you thank you yeah jail texted me
like God Brendan's trying to get
emotional with me again yeah
it hasn't he learned MMA Pro since 2001.
2001 sir
are you [ __ ] kidding me that's how
long that guy he is so durable it's
weird wait Ben Rothwell or Ben Henderson
Ben roethlis because Ben Henderson's
fighting this weekend I thought you
meant Ben Henderson I'm talking about
Ben roethlis oh yeah Ben Ben roethlis
been playing forever Legend really good
dude too that's insane Ben Henderson's
fighting this weekend in Bellator ninja
story about me and Ben Henderson I've
told us before uh shop or food truck I'm
sure with me and Ben
um when he first started I was holding
the door it was the first Jitsu gym ever
went and I was holding the door for him
and he goes what's up we're friends
right away because we're new and like
what's up Bros what's up I'm here what
are you doing here he's like I'm sure
same thing you're trying to get to the
UFC I was like me too it's my first day
he's like you'll love this Coach man his
name's John Crouch that's where he
opened the MMA uh lab up with so me and
him started together me and Bear
Henderson yeah and he was such a stud
yeah so uh was he the toothpick guy yeah
that's so crazy he stopped doing it
though because his kids yeah he has uh
the cutest kids his kids started to put
toothpicks in their training now he's
like no what the [ __ ] why did he do it
and how was it allowed first time he
forgot first time he forgot and then
realized when he had in his mouth and
knock on so he just hit on his lip and
then he won and she kept it going but
nobody stopped there he hit it no he hit
it he hit it right there his wife fights
too oh [ __ ] been such a good person and
stupid athletic yeah you don't even see
Alpha like that do this yeah he told me
that a long time dude I'm first day
training with him I was like what in the
[ __ ] yeah I come from D1 football in the
NFL at the time so pretty and I was like
holy [ __ ] dude and John crap she's like
he's gonna be jamming his speed no just
his the athletic [ __ ] he's able to do oh
really it's like Chris uh Barnett like
dude you watch his like Instagram him
dance and stuff yeah like what the [ __ ]
explosive and have you seen his head
kick knockout yes okay
nuts and he's just like the UFC darling
now yeah and I was telling such a shame
because because he missed weight by a
pound and a half because that [ __ ]
Doctor Who was in in on the conspiracy
with Hamza too but that [ __ ] doctor was
like no you're fine I'm pounding half he
didn't you know he had the best comeback
of the night they get they're gonna
performance tonight so he didn't get his
50 Grand bonus
how ridiculous so he's out 50 Grand the
guy that really needs 50 Grand he said
something about they took he said they
just discretionary bonuses yeah that's
what he said he was a good take care
he's he's a you can see he's going to be
a crowd favorite man he's [ __ ] great
oh you know I'm telling you I've had
everybody else y'all nobody more
likeable dude yeah I I was blown away
and I said dude after this fighting
thing wait like two or three years
before you jump into entertainment
because you take my job like everything
you see here you could easily do any of
this where is he from uh he originally
born in uh Spain because Dad was in the
Air Force bony is five they moved to
Georgia so he calls Georgia home check
this out uh his family owns the
taekwondo gym so his dad's like ninth
degree black belt mom I can see the
Taekwondo oh yeah you know his brother
uh like high high level competition
black belt and then he was like so my
brother's like you know we'll kicking
everybody knocking him out he's like a
superstar in uh Georgia he said so I
have to find my own thing he's like
that's when I started wrestling I'm
thinking I was really good at wrestling
and he said he's funny because his dad
wanted to go to the NFL and then they he
was like he says funny he was a
sophomore in high school he's a monster
he's a d tackle full back like nobody
could stop me I [ __ ] everybody D1 guys
ought to destroy these guys he's like
then my dad was like hey son there
there's not a lot of five six D tackles
in the NFL man we don't want to think
about something else smart yeah smart
yep and then they started fighting and
you know he's been all over man but he
said when he was in uh fighting overseas
in Asia they're like hey we need you to
get to 320. you know so I get off he
goes dude I fly out there from Georgia
to [ __ ] Japan or China where he's
fighting I get off the plane like we're
taking all you can eat sushi and filming
it he's like I fight tomorrow they're
like yeah he's like they just wanted him
like this [ __ ] they want the number
freak they want the big freak he's like
it was not healthy like you look at
those fights that when I was 3 30 he was
like it was not hell yeah that's how
that's where I got when I watch him
but then and then what else uh is great
about him is he uh
I asked him I said uh you know obviously
right now you know your big deal
everyone's talking about you you like
all your hard work is like over 30
fights I mean that's a hot second yeah I
said so you like you burst on the scene
now but you've been putting it in the
work look how big he is there
he's hilarious but he was saying uh damn
he's big and then I said how far are you
going to take this like do you look at
like fighting Jon Jones and Francis and
Gano because
obviously his height is a detriment not
heavyweight with those big boys yes you
know what his answer was and I figured
most guys go I'll be champ guaranteed
but he goes I I take it one day at a
time dude once my wife passed away yeah
I that I don't take anything for a guy
he's got two children he goes I'm just
oh yeah and he's a great dad he goes I'm
just trying to get through tomorrow so
you're asking me the next fight
yesterday I came to Jon Jones he's like
uh what are you talking about that's so
far in the future he goes I'll get
through tomorrow I'll get on playing
I'll get my kids to school train I go
day by day man it's the only way I can
get through you know what happened to my
wife he goes I don't take anything for
granted and you're like [ __ ] dude can't
help but [ __ ] love this how do you
not love him well that's funny too when
you get to know guys look at this fall
in love with them oh dude I'm I'm done
oh Jesus Christ
he said it's funny too because it comes
from a Taekwondo family his his mom and
dad and brother when he got home after
that wheel kick they'll be like you know
you could have like they critique
everything they're like man you know if
you could you just your foot should have
been here really yeah like you could
take you everything
hey Mom Dad yeah you know thanks but
such a [ __ ] good dude he didn't
wrestling college she wrestling High
School wrestled in high school and then
he was like 23 or 24 uh he was like
school just wasn't for me he said he was
at a club dancing and he said he'd mix
in his Taekwondo like spinning back
kicks he was like the spinning back
kicker real kick looks like you're
dancing if he goes because I throw it
like I normally do and then I just add a
little something to it he's like so I'm
hammered on the Dance Floor sweating
everywhere and this these people come to
me like holy [ __ ] that big dude can move
and they go hey man tomorrow's tryouts
for the MMA team and he's like what time
though 6 a.m he's like it is 4 a.m sir
oh [ __ ] like can you come he's like [ __ ]
it I'll go so he goes and they're having
open tryouts and he's hitting mitts he
said I've never boxed before I've never
done Jujitsu he's like nowhere sparring
and he's like well [ __ ] him do my you
know bread and butter wheel kicks whack
some dude gets [ __ ] real kid in the
head and everyone's like holy [ __ ]
you're in he said five weeks later took
my first MMA fight
damn
[ __ ] that's that's uh who who was
that way who was talking about that what
I think it was even boss rooten who said
he he didn't even like ha he said he and
Mark hunt kind of taught themselves or
maybe it was Mark hunt who didn't
actually have a lot of training and kind
of taught himself boss rooting that's
boss okay and but he said
busted yeah a lot of his training
himself a lot of videos
oh boss one of the freakiest athletes
ever yeah in sports it's been giant
Dutch dude freak you're in his Prime
when he's in that [ __ ] singer yeah
and boss mentally
as far as athletes go yeah I don't care
what sport is yeah boss you know he's
got this whole street fighting thing
with my buddy I'm Eric Perez on uh on
his YouTube thing and uh I think it's
doing boss left California when I was
going to tour uh then right when the
pandemic hit I was leaving for Boise
when I was about theater in Boise did he
go he was at the airport and I I go are
you on my flight and goes yeah I go oh
[ __ ] yeah man come to the show he said
yeah we will if we have time he goes I'm
I'm I can't deal with LA anymore man I'm
out like we have a school here he's like
I'll still fly back and help with the
school but damn he was like I'm gonna uh
me and my wife are getting out of here
amazing so yeah I think he moved either
Texas or Nashville good friend or or
Montana one of them he's great you know
what I was uh watching last night man
over three weren't skinny that is me to
a team that's me
um you know what I was watching uh last
night which was ridiculous it's on Hulu
it's called Ted it's about Ted Kaczynski
got really into the unibomber you know I
just jump onto one sure I really need a
Unabomber a lot of you know he hated
like the uh the Industrial Revolution
like it was so against it so against
technology
he was against technology because he was
like the machines are going to take us
over correct he was very anti-left he's
seen how the left is ruining things and
he went in even back then which you're
talking about when he wrote the
manifesto which I stayed up
I stayed up to two in the morning
reading all his Manifesto some of it I
agree with but um he uh that was in 93
yeah 93. now obviously the killing an
extremists what are you doing here yeah
hey hey bro don't be sending mail hey
don't blow up the guy that owns the
computer shop well he was he was trying
to kill the people that were
spearheading all the research I think
initially so he'd send it to like
college Labs yeah Utah his first first
one sent to Cal I'm sorry Northwestern
like a lot of professors stuff like that
he hated the wokeness when it came to
like he would put into terms like when
we call women broads and he was saying
you know back in the day that's like now
calling a dude a bro or what's up man
he's like so you guys take his
derogatory term he talks about other
terms like that and how we're getting
too sensitive it's not good he makes up
with technology and he's running a lot
of stuff and so you know besides bombs
and killing so a lot of it was insane
right but this he he foresaw how woke
Google and Facebook and Twitter and
YouTube were gonna be well you you know
you're talking about a legit genius
controlling all that information 165
yeah he was a math genius he was
runner-up in the fields medal right yeah
and then and then went to Harvard when
he was ready 16. yeah well when you're
when you're I think look that up chin I
think he was runner-up in the fields
medal in math which is the like the
Nobel Prize in math and he would praise
he would tutor kids it really yeah you
tutor kids for money because he didn't
give a [ __ ] about money really but just
do it so he could afford bomb damn but
they were saying he was uh so smart you
know it took him 18 years to catch him
18 years because he went to
secluded Montana and his boss it was
impossible to achieve the level of
success he did and only about a dozen
folk in the world understood his PhD
thesis yes because he was really a
genius is genius the one guy Geniuses
regard as Geniuses
was he couldn't teach Yep this is
extremely typical for people who are
Ultra smart and not because they
necessarily have an informal autism in
order to communicate both the speaker
and the hearer have to share enough
conceptual knowledge blah blah but but I
guess he uh
wait there's Maiden there is no way in
maybe seven to ten years of entire
cohorts they get one single student
could even be gonna talk the same
language yeah it's so it's frustrating
for him because he was working on such a
different frequency wow he couldn't
Express his feelings to people and then
respond back damn and then if they
weren't at his level he felt like
everyone was stupid and add value to his
life so he had this horrible horrible
anger issues horrible angers yeah and he
hated everybody right but what was
interesting about him too is he was so
smart like even his brother said this he
was like the problem is you have the
smartest guy in [ __ ] North America
with this you know uh ideology like he
he wants to destroy you know uh
technology so the problem is is he's so
[ __ ] smart so his bombs you know he
do his bombs they didn't catch for 18
years the most expensive Manhunt ever in
American history yeah he would write
this is such a Savage move he'd write
letters to the FBI and go suck my [ __ ]
and put the address where he's gonna
bomb it they couldn't stop it whoa
because they couldn't find it so he just
taunt the FBI but you guys are so
[ __ ] stupid he's like how have you
not caught me this is 15 years anyway
Jesus Christ yeah his his most famous
one he put FBI suck my [ __ ] and she's a
Savage so the thing is with his bombs so
you couldn't pick up what like where he
was doing it what region he was doing
obviously he's doing in Montana which me
and my son drove to my son's like get me
out of here I'm like pipe down because
that's into this weird stuff yeah but uh
his bombs he would make out of he would
uh go to like uh yard sales and buy like
forks and knives and metal and then
break it all off so he would use like
common things out for the bomb so you
couldn't if he was usually yeah his
brother I think was saw the the writing
and said it's his [ __ ] I mean act
like I'm cheering for him no his con
mother-in-law I'm sorry uh sister-in-law
but she's not a [ __ ] because she's well
when because she you know I stopped him
I'm going off I'm going off the movie
yeah she's she's actually did a service
there yeah yeah hold on hey bro you you
terrorist does he have a girlfriend no
wait why no I don't have Unabomber bro I
don't not have you like the way you're
talking about
marriage what are you crazy come on dude
he killed people no three people 17
months you got him out dude
so but the thing is is yeah his so his
uh what's sick about that I get when
people go there's something weird and
you're just such an outlier and it's
children my ex my ex was watching when
she watched narcos and when the first
one when they found love Pablo Escobar
he did she was like don't get me strong
Pablo Escobar complete she's like
Curious I mean I know he's terrible but
God I just hated seeing his wife and no
it was such a badass no no no no that's
that's Hollywood making it he's the
worst human being of all time oh
complete sociopaths his wife his wife
was an awful person yeah all bad they're
so bad they're all bad they're all
terrified because he bombed a [ __ ]
Plane full of innocent people he'll be
that you listen you're talking about
you're talking about legit terrorists
yes kill children
killer dude kill children one uh one of
the FBI agents in Mark's legs
which is a really baggy jean no he uh
the theme about Pablo Escobar is he
would blow up uh I mean several you're
talking about six to seven yeah people
were awesome it would be like blowing up
uh Target here you just blow him up
because he didn't want he want them to
uh not give uh send them in America he
wanted it he wanted to change the
literally the laws in Colombia so they
came so they couldn't extradite him yes
that's all I killed him yeah so listen
so when Rogan had that picture of his
mug shot yeah even I'm like do you got
tears on your wall you're like ah I'm
like when you look into them it's I know
we like glamorized and we we like
romanticize about dude you're talking
you might as well have Bin Laden on your
way this guy is a terrible human being
do you know you know who they and then
what they would do so I didn't what they
would do is Pablo Escobar and all the
guys El Chapo all these [ __ ] scumbags
do the same thing what they do is they
have all that money right they have more
money than God yeah and the rats are
tearing through it so they donate back
in the community so the community be on
their side like he's actually a good job
he's a good guy look he built the soccer
field he built these this housing unit
look at the field soccer field he built
for us all that stuff so then what the
community would do is they would snitch
on when people would come in and try and
catch them so they're working for them
they think he's a good guy they have no
idea what animal they're dealing with he
was a he was a king complete sociopath
complete sociopath but back to the
[ __ ] uh Ted uh movie on Hulu it's
such a good movie if you're into the
unibomber it's a little slow and if you
don't know it's a documentary no it's a
movie okay here's what's dope about the
movie I I was in the second meme I got
nothing to watch and I'm like yeah you
want to try it [ __ ] I don't really know
about him like don't worry I'll fill you
in Click never filter in but uh
I said don't wait up I'll fill in the
gas
I'm like I'm like well just sit next to
me and cuddle because she wants to watch
something funny like a [ __ ] rom-com
I'd rather be at the dentist no if I'm
not learning something I'm out but just
cuddle with me I want to see just I want
you to see this important
episode three goes no catch up she's
like this this is a funny episode I'm
like don't worry I fill in the blank
space there's gonna be like going on I
feel like click just then 20 minutes
later I'm like [ __ ] yeah here we go baby
so the thing is is when I've sold on it
is they they do a little narrative
before they film this on the exact
property where Ted Kaczynski stayed oh
they film it in his exact location yeah
they remade his little Hut and they got
all the permits and I was like oh say
less and then when there's the narrating
is from his Manifesto from his journals
they found like a journal you know 15
years over 6 000 Pages wow to the T he
would write down the how they killed the
people why he did it what materials he
used like was so detailed and then you
know he's so [ __ ] smart if we could
have just changed the trajectory of his
[ __ ] pathway
you and I befriended him when he was 14
and stayed for friends with him and he
we included in our group yeah you know
you gave Hitler that art scholarship
yeah that's what set him off that's
right so with uh it's a really good
question no that's what I'm saying like
one move thing and he's this one so this
way dude he was such so [ __ ] smart he
writing this code nobody could figure
out and it was a code and then once they
figure out like holy [ __ ] a few people
in the world know the code but he was
fluent in it it would only write numbers
it was just numbers what what full book
and numbers are you serious yeah dude
dealing with a [ __ ] Savage but then
even he so he went to a recluse Place
how about using him in jail right now
for things right like it's like well
we'll get to they think they're
punishing them we'll get to that so when
it's flourishing so um so when he went
to Montana he wanted to be recluse he
want to get away from everybody right
and he had no money but the way uh
Montana works if you squad on properly
for seven years or longer it's yours
which is insane but um so he had that
Place well the problem was is they
started to work around him like they
wanted like you know the lumber and
build [ __ ] and people would drive their
uh snowmobile snowmobiles and
motorcycles and when he would hear sound
like if a plane flew over he'd get his
gun out and shoot out the plane he's
insane oh he's crazy that he was now
when they arrested him because of his uh
wonderful uh uh uh sister-in-law when
they arrested him they diagnosed him as
schizophrenic like paranoia but they
said uh plead to insanity and we won't
give you uh the death penalty he refused
to he's like I'm not insane I'm the
smartest and if you there's a
documentary on Netflix three-part Series
where they're pleading with him his
defense lawyers are like dude just say
you're insane he's like no I'm the
smartest [ __ ] guy in this building
I'm not insane I just don't agree the
way the [ __ ] world's going it doesn't
make me insane like just please insane
to me so much easier he's like I've been
[ __ ] kill me I'm not insane I'm the
smartest guy in this [ __ ] room and
then they went behind his back pled
Insanity he fired them all represent
himself yeah Savage so they put him in
prison right isolated he gets an hour a
day to walk you know whatever
homeboy flourishing this is all he's
ever wanted so they said he writes
that's how he was that's how he was
that's all he wanted he just want to be
left alone and in there he there's no
technology there's no phone so he sees
nothing so he's
as happy as a clan so you gave him an
eight your life sentence he's
flourishing he's working on math
problems or something no no no he writes
so he has a a fan base I'm not part of
the fan club guys come on man this is
insane what are we talking about here
but uh you're a groupie yeah you're a
uniform bomber groupie dude we're called
the bombers
nobody uh with a jacket you you read his
Manifesto oh dude he's got something out
of it
she actually got something out of it and
you're gonna [ __ ] break him out of
prison no way no he'd be upset he's
flourishing in there there's a sick
thing where I know you were fantasizing
about seeing him in Montana and being
like hey I know you are just so you know
I could I I want to learn from you I'll
be winning soldiers and he'd go you're
too stupid you're too stupid right talk
to him I go make it laugh I go I know
I'll just sit in silence I won't bother
you not gonna work cause you're too
stupid right you over 160 I go I don't
know yours I'll tell you it's not so
here here's what we're gonna do don't
come back to my prison cell right I go
okay all right we can play chess they
say never mean I Crush you every time
yeah I'll do yeah I mean you'd be like
you're too stupid to be around me right
I'm like yeah you're right and you're
not and we always want to repeat he's
not in this fan club he doesn't write
them no dude I'm not an exclusive member
of the bomb squad
my pen pal name is
but he was to be honest like he was a
bit of an Intel because he could never
get a girl so there's conversations him
with his mom he's like Mom you know I've
only kissed two girls in my life I've
never had a sexual relationship in my
[ __ ] life you know that makes me feel
his mom was like why are you telling me
this stuff I don't know this he goes who
the [ __ ] else am I gonna tell he just
have nobody to talk to I don't talk to
anybody might come down to that dude it
can come down to that well the movie
does a great job they allude to a tad
and this is where you really gotta have
a black belt and Unabomber to understand
this one of his biggest kind of hiccups
was he was so mad at women so he was
working uh in Montana on uh on like a
lumber yard or whatever and he was uh
scraping the wood you know and this she
owned the her dad it was a family-owned
business but the woman was the was his
boss she drives binary TV and goes hey
Ted you're you're moving the saw towards
your genitals you got to go away from me
otherwise it's gonna clip your knots and
you're gonna be [ __ ] and he goes oh oh
I'm sorry this is real he goes oh I'm
sorry I don't take um advice from women
if you have a male
advisor please to have him advise me
because I don't listen to women and she
was like I own the [ __ ] place you're
fired he goes again you just fired me I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't listen to
females you're like so he wasn't all
there well he just so he was we just had
such an animosity towards women because
obviously they didn't like so it's like
the same thing like these you know this
this to me this is a representative of
society right now like um when you think
about it
you know there's guys who report only
like hot only fans girls to the
government so they get taxed and if they
don't pay their taxes they get shut down
seriously who are these guys there's a
group of themselves these are guys who
hate women that report or or you know
there's no
let's take a break guys I'm gonna be
this weekend Spokane Comedy Club let's
go
um Thursday Friday Saturday in Spokane
comedy I mean Expo Kane Washington
Tacoma Washington the weekend after that
come right back up I gotta make my
tickets [ __ ] I haven't bought my tickets
yet September 29th September 30th
October 1st Bridgeport Connecticut
Stress Factory October 13 14 15.
Schaumburg Illinois Chicago improv
October 27 28 29. there it is uh let's
talk a little bit about CBD okay now
listen I don't know how it works I don't
know why it works but next Evo Naturals
next Evo Naturals was developed by smart
sword technology which is clinically
clinically proven to help your body
absorb CBD four times better than
regular CBD oil it really is about what
you absorb not what you eat
because oil doesn't mix well it doesn't
mix with your water-based body it
doesn't just mix with your water-based
body it works faster too and when you
feel stress coming on
you don't have to worry about wondering
if it's working okay
so smart startup technology improves
cbd's ability to be absorbed it gets in
your system in as little as 10 minutes
most CBD oil found in tinctures gummies
and capsules achieved between two
percent and 10 absorption absorption
which means that 90 of what you think
you're getting is actually wasted next
Evo Naturals are scientifically
formulated to to deliver more CBD in a
way your body can actually use and fast
they're proven 29 times better
absorption in the first 30 minutes
whatever the case with CBD it does seem
to truly grow I mean I'm sorry truly
work on a lot of things including a
friend of mine who's suffering from
seizures
um you know you can say whatever you
want but you know he swears by it so
they're vegan they're GMO free they're
gluten free THC they're THC free so
you're not gonna be high and they're
derived from 100 U.S grown hemp so stop
wondering CBD is right for you try next
Evo Naturals capsules gummies mints and
topical creams clinically proven to be
better absorbed by your body gets 25 off
your first order or forty dollars or
more at next evo.com with promo code
fighter that's 25 off at next evo.com
promo code fighter
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com promo code fighter
listen listen if you're going to take
supplements you better know where
they're sourced you better know where
they're coming from you better know that
it's a very reputable company how about
how about a company that was started by
people that started by taking the actual
supplements themselves and still do
today even even I don't know people like
Joe Rogan who sold his company but still
takes Alpha Brain seen it with my own
eyes is as recently as I don't know a
month ago all right so when it comes to
your focus when it comes to your Memory
Alpha Brain is the top sell you know
there's times when you're so into what
you're doing you can't think about
anything else times when you're like in
that flow State you're you're focused
well psychologists call that that zone
the Flow State Alpha Brain from on it is
the ultimate way to get there
it it is a nootropic supplement with
over a million bottles sold okay and
that's the one thing I would always say
is like what why do you take Alpha Brain
I'd ask Aubry Marcus or Joe and they'd
be like well because it works Brennan
takes it every time we do a podcast it
works it improve it promotes cognitive
functions including memory mental speed
and focus and it can help you remember
names zero in on complex tasks think
more clearly under stress
um it contains amino acids and plant
compounds that promote the brain's
release of alpha waves that's how it
works which are associated with greater
creativity and productivity and at the
same time it supports neurotransmitters
chemicals that relay information in and
out of the brain so if coffee and energy
drinks make you jittery you can rest
easy knowing that Alpha Brain is
caffeine free you're not going to get
jittery all right save up to 10 of your
order by going to on it.com slash
f-a-t-k that's on it.com slash
f-a-t-k all right we got Dave Rubin here
Dave Rubin of the Reuben report Dave
Rubin my friend friend of the show and
Dave Rubin who I I loved your book don't
burn this this book Thank you are we
gonna even do a show we just did a show
without we just did it well we started
we just do because I'm gonna run through
a brick wall well but but Dave you're
hanging out with DeSantis you're hanging
out with these people so I get all my
inside scoop I would go to his house for
like dinners and it'd be just the
smartest [ __ ] but the movies
and shakers and I'd get all this inside
information and you always played smart
very well yeah yeah
you were smart and people said you'd go
to the bathroom and people would be like
he might we like that guy
what's the deal and if they if they
started to get there I'd start making
them laugh then I then I do a dick joke
yep now excellent Brian Smart got the
smart people water right like this you
got them water at the end of the night
that's what I was doing water boy he's
The Waterboy yeah that's correct you are
a great house guest by the way because
you always bring a great bottle of wine
yes guys you don't make a mess very
pleasant and he'll dance he'll entertain
like you don't have to do any work if
Brian's probably not any dancing we've
not done any dancing but that's a couple
orgies
orgies for sure my my uh my fiancee soon
to be my wife is oh I got the invitation
we need to talk about this I know
just fire off Imitation a wedding I'm
like what I know I'm eloping and then
I'm having a party if you're in town
yeah yeah you're in town
to people because otherwise now you got
to fly all the way across the country
honestly you know I'm here for 24 hours
right now I don't want to be here I'm
happy to be here with you people but you
hate tally I hate Cali
never come back to L.A if this is the
last time I'm here it will be a joy my
life will have gone right I love Miami I
love Miami I love Florida I love freedom
I love lizards iguanas I got frogs in my
pool I love it yeah it's sunny
everything's alive you have a baby you
know how dead it looks here do you see
that when you're I mean we're you're in
a nice spot well I'm in Calabasas and I
live out here it looks pretty freaking
dead again compared to Florida it's
green it's alive yes the humidity you
get a little glisten on the skin you
said I walked in you said it's fired I
know you do look good you look better I
haven't taken my eyes off your hair this
whole time oh his hair dude there's
something about David it might be wealth
it might be just success in general it
might be it might be being on the right
side of History where he's he's one of
the investors in [ __ ] Rumble yeah and
said hey you should invest and I was
like I I can't believe you did invest in
that big I didn't have you I didn't give
you my number dude I've been so into it
yeah I've been so into it before I
dropped the ball oh my God it's about
three years ago I said Brian I got this
thing cooking locals we're gonna do
something with Rumble like it's all
happening I don't need it we didn't even
need money but I was like I wanted to
get myself if you know what the
California divorce laws are but you
they're not good yeah
drop your boy colonel just a crime you
didn't even say yeah no I didn't know I
didn't know you're part of Rumble and I
didn't negotiate actually if I remember
correctly I said when you said you
couldn't do it the divorce and I said
well what about Brandy and I think your
quote was [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] that guy yeah he's got enough money
so the rumble is it just went public it
just went public I'm going tomorrow
morning 9 30 a.m to NASDAQ to ding it's
so weird you're here I'm dinging the
Bell man yeah and and so so it feels
like Rumble is is
gonna be as big in many ways as
something like YouTube because people
are so baby do you know who they've
signed can I fill them in so they have
uh Andrew Tate yep pretty big I don't
know if you know Transit ridiculously
Russell Brand you ever heard of him one
of the most Brilliant Minds in the world
fantastic yeah monsters yeah monsters
when you yes
when you when you uh censor people yeah
when you do it anonymously when you do
it when your rules are very hard to
follow
um and when you ultimately are the
Arbiter of free speech yeah you're going
to create another market and that's what
I love about but it's also with YouTube
is the algorithm where there's no gray
space there's no it's very black and
white so if I said something like
you know anti-nazier anti so that gets
flagged just as that word was said yeah
even though you're not uh an advocate of
whatever you're gonna say vaccines
covered lockdowns whatever it is that
gets picked up in the algorithm the
problem is the problem is none of it
makes any sense and that's by Design you
know what I mean like the the confusion
of all of it is by Design so that you
can never really pinpoint oh this is the
bad guy this is the trick at YouTube or
anything else so we know when there are
months when suddenly like my channel
literally two months ago we had our best
numbers ever then suddenly we have our
worst numbers ever and it's like that's
not we all know we've only been in this
game long enough you know when you're
doing good stuff and it's resonating I
just finish up a freaking massive sold
out book tour in every city I go to and
suddenly my number is plummeted yeah
it's like yeah well that was interesting
how come you're not on the New York
Times bestseller list I should have been
number two this time I mean that's the
thing you can see it they [ __ ] with
everything numbers numbers right so New
York Times I should have been number two
anyone can fact check me on this it's
all there and if you combined audio with
actual physical books I would have been
number one but they do it separately but
they didn't even put me on the list they
don't put me on the first time which
they weren't happy with I should have
been I think number three they put me at
11. nobody cares about any of this
nonsense except uh to show that if
they're screwing with numbers sales
numbers right it's a it's a it's a legit
thing you think they might be messing
with the news yeah how far do they go
you know or silencing or also and we
know this for a fact like with the codes
of misinformation now we know that those
people that you banned and kicked off it
was misinformation we know it's not
misinformation and now it's all good but
they still didn't unban those people so
what is the agenda here I would love to
hear Joe Biden if you get the covid
vaccine you will not transmit or get
covet that's Joe Biden in June of last
is that misinformation is that
misinformation I think he's still on the
Twitter right but for me he just came
out on 60 Minutes said the the code
pandemic's over and then fauci was like
no no no no no
you know what we [ __ ] up and what
happened was we were learning as we went
along I'd be like I get it you're human
but there's none of that sort of me a
couple there's no humility there's no
[ __ ] humility that's my problem with
Newsom he puts his nose times like we
did everything right I'm like there's no
way you can lay your head down at night
and think you handle this the correct
way let me say in that I'm getting on a
plane to get out of this dystopian
nightmare in a few hours Gavin Newsom is
the evilest soulless lizard person
horrible human being if he even
qualifies as a human can I push back on
that for a second yeah is it possible
is it possible that Gavin Newsom is is
maybe whether he's a good guy or a bad
guy is it possible he's just not he's
not dealing with a lot of mental
horsepower is it possible he's not that
that's my fault don't run for a [ __ ]
president but I always feel like he's be
I can finish his sentences because he's
just touting it's almost like he's
reading from a text yeah nothing's
original no and so I I know what he's
going to say so global warming know what
you're going to say yeah covet know what
you're going to say uh gun control know
what you're gonna say Roe v Wade know
what you're gonna say I I can I know
what he's gonna say so you've got this
mouthpiece yeah and I've actually never
and I've tried I'm trying to be terrible
I've never heard him really speak from
his party and I know people that know
him well is this your defense of him
that he's yeah
he's probably not about
no he's evil I'll tell you why just
ambition yes yes because everything this
man touched look he's gonna [ __ ] hey
take it easy no dude the reason I like
you guys there's many reasons but the
red pilling that has gone on with you
guys that was seen in real time which is
exactly what happened to me just maybe a
little bit earlier it's like it's very
clear where you guys are at and it's
clear where like someone like Rogan's
out on it and we're Bill Mars on it
everyone's on that responding to
evidence yeah I'm not a red pill I'm
responding I am like you say in your
book I am an old school liberal I
believe in gay marriage I believe in
legalizing drugs or at least definitely
marijuana I I just believe in the
Constitution you believe in reality
that's basically it that's basically and
I think most people are that way when we
were being told that even saying that
this coveted pandemic could have been
started in a Chinese lab and then we
were being told that if we said that we
were racist those kinds of things when
you start demonizing Brian they did that
to your president they they ostracized
the president States because he said man
I think this was like from a lab it's
the Chinese flu right Kung Fu and Frank
which is hilarious and frankly and
there's a joke and also I don't know
they lock us back down I'm gonna storm a
[ __ ] Whole Foods I'm telling you man
I'm that uh this is even on your radar
that you that a lockdown could even
affect your life monkey do you know
what's happening monkey pox just stay
out of bath houses having orgies with
people that are having sex with a monkey
right it's boring yeah yeah yeah no I
mean I hear you man I I think that it's
obvious you have made a real impact and
a business on kind of just going I I
this doesn't make sense to me it's
basically I I exist in reality yeah I
exist there are basic truths there are
differences between boys and girls like
basic [ __ ] that we all know we're all
roughly like within how many years how
many times
35 years old I mean I'm young as [ __ ] no
no no
I feel like you're yeah so you're 55 I'm
46. 39. okay so that's a nice like Gen X
like you're a little bit ahead of me on
that you're a little bit
younger
our age people should be in charge right
now and instead we've got these
geriatric buffoons and I don't mean that
to make fun of old people you Thomas
soul is 93 years old you get him out
there I'd vote for that guy the guy I
told you about it oh I got that book uh
black rednecks and uh about those great
book for the place if you're looking to
get to the end of the road that's the
book and just finish it he's a tower out
of that and the Unabomber is Manifesto
different End of the Road different end
of the road all interesting all
interesting yeah but keep going but but
the point is that that our age people
should be in charge right now right we
have a little bit of knowledge a little
bit of world weariness we're still
physically okay instead we're being led
by freaking Pelosi and Biden and even
Trump and everything like these these
upper 70s 80s dinosaurs get out of the
way that is part of the problem yeah
they cannot let go and I don't mean that
like old people cannot be good because
of course they can and there's a lot of
lot to learn but man they have to get
out of the way and our our general the
Gen X thing where we put a lot of the
[ __ ] to bed too did you guys grow up
with any real racism it was like just
simply no no I didn't hear the n-word
going to school I mean people did and
there was I'm not saying racism didn't
exist but certainly you were taught and
I'm 55 I was taught from day one that
treating somebody for the way they look
or for these trades but also for for my
age group Our Heroes were all black like
Michael Jordan
every poster in my bedroom was was
either a black wrestler or or a black
NBA player basically what was the number
one show
1989 in the world it was The Cosby Show
a father who was an obstetrician and a
wife who was a lawyer upper middle class
family people they wouldn't put that
show on now because it would be too
against what the system wants you to see
right I mean that's pretty whacked
that's putting aside Cosby yeah but also
to your point uh Dave is like what
you're doing I think the majority and I
know because I see it because I I travel
so much as a comedy I'm torn everywhere
most people are in line with you the
majority of America is aligned with you
but on social media the loudest these
extreme left and right especially the
extreme left who control a lot of these
platforms and are so loud on there
people think that's the majority if
they're caught up in that social media
world and I'm I'm like dude I'm telling
you that's not real I mean I'm trying to
ask you both a question yeah bro Chen
bring up USA today's women of the year
and I want to ask you as somebody who
knows how many of them are women well
yeah well yeah well in fact I already
know where this is going I'm glad you
asked yeah I'm glad you asked because
we've got now let me just see rupali
Desai this attorney defended the
Integrity of the 2020 presidential
election and helped launch a
recreational marijuana program I guess
that's worth it now hold on Heather [ __ ]
Richardson in her popular daily
newsletter letters from an American she
empowers marginalized groups who say who
she says are more important than ever to
the political landscape meaning she
writes a newsletter that marginalized
groups don't [ __ ] read from this old
white woman she means old white liberals
yeah now keep going the only one on
those Simone biles about it yeah
absolutely you lost me with Kamala
Harris even women some of them some of
them are great I wanted to see them
and and and uh that's an interesting one
that's an interesting one
um I'm not going to get into that but it
is interesting that lot of these people
when I was reading what they did Melinda
Gates yes Nina Garcia yes I get it I'll
even give you Kamala Harris no you know
um you believe this thing yeah I didn't
realize I didn't realize but but but but
what do you think is the to what degree
is this politics it's USA Today though
who the [ __ ] reading that who makes
these you know Jordan you know is it a
cat is it a is a committee it's just a
nothing remember the never-ending story
The nothing what were they fighting it
was the nothing and what was the nothing
it was just a place where there was no
creativity there was no thought there
was no imagination and it the movie ends
with the kid having to use his
imagination to restart the thing that's
what these things all are the New York
Times all the the world economic Forum
all these things they're big nothings no
one they don't really represent most of
us who are living what you said yeah
like there's no individuality to it so
it's just this generic can we get peeps
oh that woman said something about
something related to diversity put her
on a list that guy chopped his dick off
put them on the list as a woman like
none of it makes any sense how did we
get to the point where gender yeah is
the only thing A lot of people are
talking about as if it's the it is the
largest crisis to me when we start
focusing on that stuff it's like well on
the news the problems with the shootings
and racing so are those problems not as
big as you guys make it out to be
because if we have time to focus on this
other stuff right do you want to put all
these resources in the focus on that the
pronouns and all that [ __ ] well I
thought this I thought we had real
problems over here right should we put
out this fire is it is it that is it
that somebody said hey we have children
who have gender dysphoria and their
suicide rates are at least 32 to 50 well
lockdown that's a disaster and then you
had a bunch of activists who said we
have to stop this because there are
people that feel like they're a
different body and a different thing
whatever you want to call that yeah
um is it it did it create an Evangelical
movement of the these people that
decided that's the that's the only thing
worth worrying about and if you dead
name anybody they will commit suicide
and you're ultimately killing people how
do you have any idea of the origins of
this having been with Jordan Peterson
and all that well first off you know the
Jordan thing's interesting because
Jordan I had Jordan on my show for the
first time in uh I believe it was
December it was either December 2016 or
January so way back before any you know
it was just he was just this little
known maybe in Psychology really it's
brilliant I was the first guy that's why
Rogan called me and said no [ __ ] that
guy Jordan Peterson's great I think I
was literally I might it be I might be
literally the first podcast what was he
even talking about at the time because
that was kind of before the general news
yeah he had just been about colleges
because is that when he got uh released
I didn't know nobody knew who he was he
was just an obscure journalist that my
friend Hunter mods said we should get
this guy on brain he's yep he's standing
up to I think it was 2014 2015 said he's
standing up to
um this college that wants to censor him
and and basically uh because he said
he's not going to be compelled to call
these people by their phone no oh so
we're I think I think you have the date
a little bit off because that was around
2016. because that was Bill's season
right after that
sometimes you said Jordan just give me
10 I'll put you I'll connect you with
the road well I put I hope I'm thinking
like I hope Jordan I miss out on Rumble
their biggest Club yeah so you're
welcome and that's why I get no love hi
Justin how are you yeah I think I'm done
with CAA that's a different topical
together I can't work with these people
anymore I like Justin a lot Justin's
awesome I love Justin but what I can't
work with the machine anymore just
endless suck machine Dave what are you
paying these people for nothing it's
like yeah you know what I got the same
person this guy over here I got my
producer over here in Phoenix I just had
this exact same conversation I just
don't need these guys anymore they're
mostly Justin is Justin is seriously an
awesome dude I'm not talking about just
but also but also what would you say you
do for them no they don't do anything I
just went on tour everything they did
was actually a pain in my ass more than
helping me well you may not need an
agent yeah maybe at a point in your
career where you don't need but also the
game's changing too like you know also
that's an old model like back in the day
like movie stars and comics and stuff
they needed a lot of that stuff and now
like what you do you have access to
everything that you need it's like I
can't I can call any comedy club and
just be like what are your dates yes why
should I give this guy money for 10 for
calling me yeah I'm cold geez yeah for
going yeah Dave yeah he's open and do it
cool like 10 you're like wait hold on
that's what that's but so but it's an
old it's an old it's an old model before
I get out of town tonight well what what
no no what CA is good at if you're an
actor is that they package deals right
right so so they you're in the business
if you're with CAA you're gonna get
first dibs as an actor of that script
but B I'm saying actors still need it
right they need the rules but the talent
that we have like what we do these
different kind of they really don't know
what to do with it social media when you
have the talent that the three of us
have I don't see how you possibly need
to work with anyone because you can just
like this it's all over the world baby
uh anyway Peterson uh so it was about
2016 he was warning about Bill c-16 this
is where they were going to compel
speech and that if you literally
accidentally if you were walking down
the street and you said good day ma'am
and it turned out to be a dude they
could he was worried that what this bill
would ultimately do is you would be
fined or jailed it's happening now it's
happening in Ireland right now a teacher
has been jailed because of this for
misgendering a student and then yeah the
the administration it's a little more
complex than that the school said don't
come back to school anymore you
misgendered this kid then he came back
then the courts got involved they
literally threw him in jail uh so Jordan
was way ahead on all this so your
question was well where is it all coming
from
it's hard to say exactly what that is
it's sort of like saying who's in charge
of Biden it's like it's like who's in
charge of the machine you're asking me
like the meaning influential professors
I think that that came out of Yale in
different places then it just sort of
morphed into and then you throw the big
Tech piece and the algorithms of what
get clicks and who they ban and all of
this stuff and it's just
just a system of control that's it you
know what I mean it just is the gender
stuff is complete nonsense no one you
want to chop off your genitals that's
fine but this stuff with kids and that
if you've now try to make sure you know
because the thing is it's actually also
very anti-gay I think maybe we talked
about this once over dinner like if you
take if you see a 12 year old boy that's
a feminate just a feminate most likely
he's just going to grow up to be a gay
man hopefully a functioning gay man
that's what the literature says that's
it or or a girl who's a tom girl maybe
she'll be a lesbian but but actually
maybe not we all go through phases and
whatever if you start confusing a young
mind with this idea that you might be a
boy or a girl there's going to be a lot
well to have 12 people a lot of parents
that end up in really bad nursing homes
when their kids are in charge of their
lives and they realize man my parents
had me chemically castrated or when my
brain wasn't even that's what I'm saying
your brains develop for that to make
that big of a life decision like I
always uh equal to when I was a kid my
favorite movies RoboCop yeah can you
imagine like Hey Dad I want robotic arms
he's like you're 12 dude when you're 21
just give me a nightmare but my dad was
like yeah let's do it yeah then I'm
[ __ ] 24 30 years old I got these
[ __ ] robotic arms like Dad why would
you why would you allow me to do this
thing that's what you wanted to do it
doesn't say people would be like that
does sound pretty that sounds way cooler
but you anybody like that's insane you
let this 12 year old make that
life-changing decision yeah we're doing
it we're like no that's how they feel
it's like they're 12. yeah that that's
where I have a real problem and I think
it's worth fighting for well they also
had children grow up let them let their
brains develop and then let them well
there should be a minimum age like you
know if you want to buy alcohol you'd be
21 but if I want to chop my dick off
it's all as long as my parents say it's
all good I can go do it right well it's
you can't do that yet it's sort of like
uh it's sort of like the stuff with with
voter IDs it's like if you say you want
voter IDs you should just have an ID to
vote which every country in the world
has we all know it's obvious we don't
have it here in California which is why
when I voted for Larry Elder in the
recall I literally took out my my wallet
because I was about to show the guy my
ID and he freaked out like as if I was
handing him a bag of cocaine you know
what I mean like really yeah because
they don't want to see your ideas but
yet you have to show an ID if you go to
a freaking mini golf place so that they
you know you don't steal the golf club
correct so it's like all of these things
that we know are true and obvious and
simple if you said to anybody you know
they'll say if you want voter ID it's
racist well it's okay so somehow they're
saying black people can't get IDs which
is insane and racism
but so are there black people that are
not getting on planes because they
because you need an ID to get on a plane
so are we and if there are they have an
apartment or get a car or anything yeah
I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about I literally can't follow
this yeah this is insanity but you know
it it really like the red pilling is
just it's happening like it's happening
across the board I don't know if you saw
this clip in the last couple days that
was going around of Woody Harrelson on
Bill Maher's podcast no and basically
he's just he's like so red pilled like
the government is awful at everything
why would you be want them involved in
anything your health your job yeah Woody
and he's sitting there he's got no shoes
on he's baked out of his mind Mars baked
you know but but it's like man Woody
Harrelson is making more sense than
freaking faucy
will be ostracized Bill Morris kind of
sort of been almost the he's created by
Red pilled he's sipping some red tea
there are a lot of people that are that
are trading his his fantastic monologues
Insanity yeah well I'm gonna be working
on him tonight you're going on you're
going on more tonight I'm going on MAR
tonight
the podcast not the podcast they've
given me the boot on the show a couple
times why is that
my gut feeling would be that I I sort of
was in the Bill Maher old school liberal
thing for a long time and then I I kind
of got to the end of the road he's not
there so it might expose him a little
bit too much he might be at the end of
the road but he can't say it or he's a
Hollywood guy and by the way that that's
legit too he has built a certain life in
a certain place and whatever
um I would hope that he would be truly
saying what he believes at the end but
he's getting there but he also he has to
play the game too because you think
you're like a guy like Chris Pratt right
like Dave really ostracized him yeah
yeah yeah him all it was was that he
literally went to church I mean the [ __ ]
that they pulled on Chris Pratt was
insane people hate them it's nuts they
kept saying his church was anti-gay and
it's like well wait a minute wait a
minute do you think ilhan Omar's mosque
does gay weddings yes
I think there's one mosque in the United
States that does gay weddings by the way
I'm not sure I'm not asking the
questions you're just asking questions
Dave yeah these are just questions
everybody you see why I'm not going to
be on YouTube much longer I Can't
Describe
yeah you guys had a good ride yeah we
had a good run you had a good one you
should be on Rumble and again I will
next time you come to my house when I
open up the door of the room with all
the cash yes yes right yeah it could
have been news it's just wet my tongue
just rub my beak a little bit David
apologize I got my hand hat in my hand
i'm disgusting ashamed with myself and
then Sammy the book comes up we got to
play some we got to play ball otherwise
I got a problem you know yeah well
congratulations it's good it's good I've
been fantasize about it's gonna kick
myself honestly joking aside like I I
started locals because I saw a problem
with big Tech I had no idea if we could
do I didn't know what I was doing and in
retrospect it's crazy that I built a
tech company I I had no idea what I was
doing I spent more time in the last
three years working on locals and then
all the other stuff that everyone knows
me about because building a tech company
and getting investors and having to sit
around those tables full-time Zoom calls
every day for hours repeating the same
stuff it was hard I'll tell you one
great story about the investor thing
though so we had gotten a couple
investors things were kind of growing
the numbers were looking good but we
knew we needed like one or two more to
really give us some some room right some
Runway so I'm at a meeting in Miami
about a year and a half ago before I
moved here
and uh I'm sitting at this table with
like 10 big time investors and I'm doing
the same Spiel I've always done and
finally in the middle of dinner I was
like I can't keep repeating this [ __ ]
it's like making me crazy you know like
it's like do you guys see it or not so I
went on my locals app so that's my
community and I wrote a post and I said
hey guys I'm at a meeting with investors
right now can you just give me your
honest assessment of locals be as brutal
as you want whatever you want to say I
then I send it out it gets push
notifications so it shows up on
everyone's phone I got hundreds of
responses in five minutes I literally
I've never done this before I unlocked
my phone I said to all the investors
just passed the phone around the table
and take a look at the responses when I
ask people about this product and we got
two major investors that oh wow that's a
[ __ ] baller move yeah that's a
problem and I I didn't even look at the
responses
like yeah it could have been like this
guy's this thing
let's put these dick pics bro I'm the
American at least the American flag is
behind them but still yeah this I mean
you're a patriot but this is outrageous
so I don't know so it worked it worked
and locals locals was what exactly so
locals was my my attempt at taking out
patreon because patreon was is sense
patreon which is the crowdfunding
platform yeah you should not be on
patreon we not only should you not be on
patreon for free speech purposes our
product is a million times better you
can live stream from your phone you can
get push notifications out to people you
own all of it we just we basically build
you the house
it's still a thing so locals is now
merged with Rumble and we're the
subscription size yeah because rumbles
has because I could yeah prescription
side of yeah which is local yeah so the
two companies they they are it's sort of
like Facebook I don't want to compare
anything to Big Tech but yeah you know
Facebook and Instagram they are now
together but they're still separate did
you hear uh Mark
um yeah Zuckerberg on Rogan I did I did
I got I I was sympathetic to his issues
I'm not you're not God damn it I was
[ __ ] that dude man it's like you know
what I'm gonna go slightly with Brian on
this one because over the years as bad
as Zuckerberg is on major things an
election screw you know 450 million
dollars to fortify an election and a lot
of weird stuff and Facebook has been
guilty of all sorts of stuff when he's
been hauled in front of Congress to talk
about free speech he's pretty good you
remember that moment when AOC basically
was saying to him and she's [ __ ]
trying to be nice uh you know she
basically was like you know you're not
censoring enough stuff and he was like
well it's not my job to censor things I
believe that there's a Marketplace of
ideas and she was trying to use the
power she really said that yeah oh yeah
oh yeah incredible quiz well you're
about to defend her quit Brian I will I
would never you defend AOC I'm gonna
have to fight him I never hate you I'm
gonna beat each other with no legs you
know what right now because he's in the
room doesn't mean you're safe and I'll
come right at you you defend AOC it's I
quit the show how about I quit I will
throw David on you and then I'll beat
you I got a torn ACL in my lips
but I'm doing PRP in there too
I played full court basketball for the
first time in seven years last week and
I really freaking played great I swear I
have to wear a crazy trap Jaws so
platelet-rich therapy yeah so they take
your blood out yeah they spin it in the
centrifuge the platelets come out that's
where all the the juice all the
nutrients are and they inject it back in
you so you can't replace an a ACL but it
strengthens everything around you where
can you do that you can shoot it you can
do it almost anywhere yeah anywhere back
you can do it in your knee you can do it
for your hair your hair it helps your
hair yeah yeah I mean you know you've
always had good hair
I had uh alopecia and I had lost a ton
of hair oh and yeah and that and then I
was trying to find a remedy for that
maybe you don't try uh PRP foot
yeah I do man
yeah I do it's not cheap but I've never
had good hair you don't ever hey you
know how good your hair would look if
you just invested I got five more weeks
of my Invisalign yeah five more weeks of
my Invisalign then I'm tackling my
[ __ ] hair and I'm gonna take a
picture of Dave Rubin I'm gonna say I
want to look like that please do you
find that someone wearing Invisalign
that you're worried that other people
are thinking you're wearing Invisalign
all the time yeah because a little bit
here I'm I notice you're wearing
Invisalign it's aggravated right but you
have a great smile what are you doing
with it yeah no because now my teeth are
very straight but my blouse off and all
that he's had them on for 19. your
Invisalign are waiting at the [ __ ]
dentist and you still haven't picked
them up you know why because you can't
have a show with two guys wearing
Invisalign because we won it's a bit
much it's a bit much both of us have
that list really now one's fine here
today Reuben and we've got Dave Rubin
Rumble is that amazing there's this
thing about about Madden I think he's
trying his best
is actually a very nice person I like
LLC thank you
give me give me your assessment of
DeSantis what your predictions are I'm
gonna put you on the spot yeah you're a
guy who's got your finger on the pulse
you hang out with DeSantis you hang out
with all the who's who now did Will
DeSantis run do you think does Trump run
for sure well first off I understand
this it will never get better than him I
really mean that as a politician I'm not
saying he's perfect I'm not saying he's
Jesus I'm not saying I am just saying as
a politician in the American system
which is so freaking whacked yes you it
will never get better than this decent
guy who when we talked about the age
thing before I think he's I think he
turned 43 or 44 last week I've met the
first lady many times uh Casey she's
wonderful they have two kids he's a
Family Guy when I've spent time with him
scholar when he came and he did my last
uh my last tour stop with me you did the
one like a few days before actually uh
in Orlando so we went right to Orlando
in Disney con country and we did we did
the whole don't say gay thing crowd was
awesome we're sitting in the green room
and it's just me and him for about a
half an hour and he just want to talk
about baseball actually like he doesn't
he's just he's a decent he loves dude
yeah so he played bases
you play baseball you play baseball in
college
um you know he likes smoking cigars
whatever he's a mess so in terms of just
what you would want a politician forget
whether you agree with him on everything
he does exactly what he says he's gonna
do I have never seen a politician like
this this Martha's Vineyard thing what
did he do he said if you send these
people in we are going to send them to
Martha's Vineyard then the best part of
the story I don't know if you saw this
he got 12 million dollars in the budget
to do exactly this it's in the budget
the Democrats in Florida there's not
that many they all signed the budget
then he does it they uh they're on
Twitter calling him a racist it's like
you morons signed the budget with the
thing that
should be open and then Florida and
Texas and California have to deal with
the majority we go Oh California never
do this but Texas and Florida is they go
okay you don't think it's a problem you
deal with this what we do with you try
it out and then now they're like holy
[ __ ] we got a problem like this is what
we're saying just saying that borders
are reasonable that's what we're saying
we're saying that allowing everybody to
come over the border is not tenable it's
not possible nobody can do that somebody
has to pay for that wasn't there a guy
with a funny skin color a couple years
ago
that's the other funny scheme I don't
mean I was so racist that sounded
serious I thought you were trying to
yeah you really better get on Rumble
okay you ain't said weird wait a minute
other guy uh yeah there was another guy
who used to oh Donald Trump with the
orange skin the orange you just have to
have a border that's what makes a
country uh but the best part of it yeah
you're right they send these people
tomorrow
has a 30 acre estate there 30 Acres on
the water now it's odd he didn't offer
them I don't know maybe a quarter of an
acre to put the people and how they
could have been killed by climate change
there because it's right on the water so
maybe he was looking out for them but
these people they are more resources
there they're freaking out Chuck Todd
goes on TV on NBC they don't have the
it's an island they don't have the
infrastructure as if all the Border
towns in Texas oh they're just freaking
yeah
yeah they can imagine exactly and then
they send it to Kamala Harris's uh
resident too great so she has to look
out I'm like holy [ __ ] man this is not
it cracks me up but but that's why I'm
saying he's so good he's doing exactly
he doesn't allow the news to control the
narrative no so when a reporter says
something goes hold it hold it no you're
not getting away with that hold on and
he he mounts his defense that way and
that's what I love about it I did I did
an event with him a couple weeks ago
called the sun uh Sunshine Summit it's a
big Florida Republican thing so it's
like an all day Day event and I was
hosting it and he did not allow
mainstream press in so the mainstream
press is freaking out and he basically
said hey why would we let you in you
guys lie about everything we're just not
going to let you in wow and it was like
yeah he's just done there's a game being
played that we all know is fixed it's
like if you kept playing Monopoly with a
friend who is the banker and you kept
losing and you're like man I've been
playing really well what's good and then
you're like oh
but a lot of people keep playing but
even though you know and by the way I
know you do nothing about it we're all
on Twitter right we're all on Twitter
we're all doing these things so we're
all in the game that we know is fixed
but he is basically saying I will not
play that game well I think that what
has happened with our Legacy Media is
it's very simple most of those people
come from the same background yes yes
they go to the same schools they are
educated by the same Educators they they
go from the echo chamber of their
cloistered wealthy home homes and
they're special high schools middle
school high schools same values and when
you have a group of people in a newsroom
that have read the same books listen to
the same TED Talks have the same
experience the same reality there's no
perspective it's very difficult yeah
you're and by the way and Sam Harris
said this long time ago and everybody
said I never have I don't have anybody
in mind it was an admission of his blind
spots he said
he said I've never I don't have anybody
in my Rolodex that even smokes or served
time in the military or works with their
hands if you don't have that that's most
of America if you don't have people that
you're friends with it even listen to
sports radio those are the people that
make this country [ __ ] move bro and
if you don't if you don't know that if
you actually don't have those people at
your dinner table or you're not friends
with people like that or you're not
interacting with those people you're
gonna you're not gonna know how most
Americans feel into the master when you
start talking about your pronouns we go
I got I understand I'm a compassionate
person I got way bigger problems bro
what's the average making of what 200 in
the bank so I'm like pronounced dude I'm
just trying to get my kids [ __ ] dead
that's it but then also going Piggyback
in on the media so they've been doing
this kind of like clickbaity stuff for
how long it really started with Trump
really picked up with Trump now with
Biden the the rights in a little bit but
look at the ratings they can't continue
to go at the rate they're going because
if all the ratings are [ __ ]
especially the left CNN all it's tanking
nobody's tuning in Biden has dementia do
we all agree on that or something like
dementia good authority Dave that he had
a stutter and yes and he had no yes yes
he has a stutter so I would say that to
push back no it's it's normal when the
leader of the Free World shakes hands
with an invisible guy he's constantly
and people like or or they have to go uh
walk to your left stares her to the
right that's right you can't be the
leader kind of a classic Democrat and
pretty moderate Biden but now but nobody
and he was also tough like he's been
through terrible tragedy kind of our
Scrappy tough politics and now he can't
write a book I know a verse no you can't
write a [ __ ] bike well well he's he's
gotten to an age obviously where there
seems to be something you know I like
how they're like he's gonna run again
it's like [ __ ] no he's not but they all
are in on it together when you talk
about like they all go to the same
Schools they're all in on the Biden
thing together too when when bootage or
Kamala is like yeah he's gonna run again
and I'm gonna support him it's like you
know he's not running again we all know
he's not you know something's wrong with
him but why are you all doing it you're
all doing it because they're all just
trying to like rip the copper out of the
walls at the end you know what I mean
like they're all just trying to get a
little whatever they can get because
they're not talented these are not
people that can do anything Pete Pete
only has that job because he's gay I
always call him gay Pete on my show it's
not because I have a problem with gay
people I'm married to one but it is
because
he's the one I have the major problem I
have a problem with it yeah
my girl talking to your husband like
that yeah no you ever want to get the
Duna it's the tuna that's you yeah yeah
yeah
he does all the stuff that my wife would
do no I know he's on the phone with her
we got the duno we got the dock attack
gonna put Pete and Kamala Harris no so
think about it why do they why are they
all in on the LIE it's because Pete has
no skills he was the he was the mayor of
South Bend Indiana I have no promise
South Bend or Indiana but he had no
qualifications or anything they say okay
you're gay so you will be the
transportation secretary congratulations
Rachel Levine is a is a was a guy his
whole life married uh is that true yes
yes I'm pretty sure he still has a wang
or she whatever the point is he he or
she or whatever it is is not qualified
to be the deputy Health secretary or
like so when did she trans Kamala has
was polling at zero in her own party
when they put the lowest ever and then
and then uh uh uh what's her name
Destroyer
absolutely yes
absolutely my favorite debate of all
time
this is was it was a man yes who
probably felt like if I see I have no
problem with this but if this is
somebody who felt like a woman saw her
her his whole life at the time and then
became a woman or you know went through
that that whole thing I'm not going to
say anything disparaging about him no
but it's not about them
but you realize you are by accident
because you the way you were just
worried about your own pronouns yeah out
of your mouth yeah as a as a comic and
and everything else but I get
it
yeah
I don't see damn well better be yeah I
go both ways you know but you but my
question is to your point like is Pete
the best for the job is she the best for
the job or are they there for a reason
because they're there because they
because they're there look at look he's
gay and Pete's like yeah yeah but how is
he is the transportation guy wouldn't
not great you guys have these fine
technical people working with you yes do
you did you hire them because of their
physical yes
he's Asian yeah and I I assumed he was
good with computers there's an
implication assumed I was gay so yeah so
there you go yeah but the point is you
don't this is what confidence confidence
and you guys live in California where
the entire Machinery is run by Equity
now so you will keep bringing in worse
and worse people and the Machinery of
California will collapse it is it is in
free fall now but it will continue to
collapse and always the question is well
what is that Rock Bottom when literally
really you're hiring firefighters only
because they're trans and they said they
don't know anything about fire like will
it get to that is that true is that is
that happening well there is some level
of that yeah there's some level of that
but I meant that one actually
because it would be it's like some
comedy venues that will only put on a
certain amount of female trans Asian
they won't put the best commentary so if
there's a fire at your house imagine
some trans
uh he was born a a boy turns into a
female and they have to carry my big ass
out of the fire and can't do it and
because that is their narrative and
there might be an excellent trans
firefighter and I would love to chat
with them but if that is your qualifier
but and it's not just the physical
things
which one is going to have a problem
because California had Silicon Valley
yes and Silicon Valley a lot of these
companies like Airbnb Etc um just went
public California got a 95 billion tax
Surplus as a result of that so when
these companies went public and you got
to remember that those that Silicon
Valley was was a California was a place
where if you had an idea you could build
a company around it and make a fortune
and that brought the best it's like the
Gold Rush rightest most aggressive it
was a it was a boys network too yeah it
was boys for whatever reason seem to be
drawn to engineering and software and
all that computer guys like things like
people it's just
so you had these you had this this they
revolutionized the way we communicate
their revolutionized pretty much
everything
it's very interesting that the the the
the
Newsome machine
Etc seemed to have made it so
inhospitable to business that they have
either left Gone to Texas or found
another place to innovate because you're
not going to have it seems the same
Innovation it may be that Silicon Valley
is somewhat at least
everyone's moving to Miami well they got
so bad Elon Musk took Tesla from
California think about it you know how
big of a hit that is now granted there's
a lot of the business that bring in
Revenue here so but still a pretty big
[ __ ] hit and just Optics wise Tesla
by the way it's not just Tech although
there's a million examples of people
they're all going to Austin and Miami
that's it remember there was that tweet
from Suarez the mayor of Miami when
Keith raboy who's one of teals guys
major VC guy he was really frustrated
with Cali he sends out this tweet and
then Francis Suarez mayor of Miami he
just wrote how can I help and next thing
you know you've got everybody moving
there because I help yeah
you're not here so you don't see this I
hope you see it but if you have a
question now Newsome's did a commercial
and he's like if you want freedom oh I
saw it you've seen I saw it if you want
freedom California about Freedom we're
not taking your rights you brought about
Freedom you need to leave Florida and
you're like are you out of your [ __ ] who
told you this do you know how many
people you guys know how many people
left Cali last year you know I know the
number you know take a wild guess so
never before in the history of
California had they lost population
2020 was the first time and that lost
the population 2021 was the second time
guess how many people is it a hundred
thousand oh 350
000. but not only it's not just 350 000
people it's the people you were just
talking about it's these people massive
brain drain look at look at Rogan I mean
Rogan's an interesting case because he
signs this crazy deal with Spotify so
now he gets I don't know a couple
hundred million obviously he said then
what he's so all in he he's never coming
to La like he's so all in oh he's making
me look like a sellout oh just for being
here with you guys oh dude yeah he's
still trying to get us to come oh I'll
talk to him when I leave here and I'll
go he's stealing that [ __ ] hole I'm like
yep I'm still here dude he's like Hey
listen I'm telling you and think about
it the guy has he's he's literally the
most influential public person in the
world has the resources to do whatever
he wants sometimes top 50 most live in
California yeah you know what I mean
like he can do they could have taken
half his money he still could do more
than basically everyone on 100. the math
made more sense no I know like the taxes
and stuff he was like I'm going to Texas
okay this much money I make the time and
now he's got to set up Brenda and I were
walking through a cinema we were like oh
we're failures I've I've told DeSantis I
I honestly he's laughed when I've said
it but I I would be for Florida having
an entry tax at this point now knowing
that that's right because I didn't move
there to save money I'm saving a lot of
money obviously but it was not that it
was everything else yes it was Freedom
truly but the idea that all these people
come and I think people are really
coming and realizing what they fled so
when I'm walking my dog in my
neighborhood and people come up to me
and oh you're new you guys live over
there I always say number one I just
want you to know I am here to keep
Florida Florida because they say where
are you from and when I say Cali they
freak out I hate it and they should
freak out it's like having a zombie
infestation well it's because the people
leave California and they still vote the
same that's why but I think that's
Austin is basically super liberal and
blue now awesome awesome has a huge
problem that that is spreading
throughout Texas Florida to me is this
is the truly safe one at the moment I
agree Texas will be okay and Beto is a
freak and yeah they just have to like
get a little get some cobwebs cleaned up
or something but yeah but this 350 000
people good people you know what I mean
Phoenix my producer his family has lived
in La his entire life he left his
parents are leaving two companies out of
here yeah these are these are
functioning these aren't the people that
are burning the cities down these aren't
the people that are causing all the time
these are job makers yeah job makers and
innovators yeah and and that was what
California was about and then you added
sunshine and it was like here we go you
know my uh the house across the street
from me is for sale by the way right
across street tennis court really nice
and and can I get in on rumble or is it
to it well I'll see if I can and then
but I'm and then
I assume the housing Market's gone up
there oh it's not yeah well Miami I love
it yeah
the housing market is so crazy that when
I went down there I knew I was buying I
was like I've got to get the F out like
I'm buying a house we saw about 20
places we finally found one that we
loved it was off Market we agreed there
we agreed on the sale number I didn't
even negotiate I was like we'll take it
for that they agreed we sent them the
contract half hour later they write back
they said we want 500 000 more and we
had to say yes because you have no
leverage so that is one problem that
Florida has which is when you get this
kind of influx influx all of your
services are going to be stressed your
housing prices are going to go and I do
have a lot of sympathy and I'm actually
I want to figure out if I can do
something I've been trying I've been
discussing it on the show a little bit I
want to help the people that were the
Floridians I don't want the average
Floridian who has been there forever
right to be pushed out and I am starting
to hear more and more stories about that
so but in a way that's a I don't mean
this as a good set of problems but it's
a it's a problem because of something
good well your your property values rise
as well that you can sell your house for
more I moved to another part of Florida
but that's not that's but that's not
what you want one you want the average
guy you want the fabric of the community
there right so I so I'm trying to figure
out something that is Venice had that
problem yeah Venice when I moved there
in 1995 was a people had been there for
30 and 40 years and there was such a
fabric to that community and everybody
had small houses and everybody just knew
each other and supported each other and
you that that was so amazing it was also
dangerous though being well a little bit
but actually no no so what happened by
the time I got there was the reason I
was there tonight the RICO actor came
along so you're right so in 1993 92 it
was dangerous it was one of the most
dangerous places if not the most
dangerous place but what happened was
with the RICO Act they came in they go
they came to these gangs and they go hey
you're walking with that guy but it's my
uncle I know he's a in a gang you're not
allowed to be walking with a gang member
because you're on parole they would go
to jail all of a sudden these gangs were
like bro I can't go I gotta hold down a
job I can't go back to [ __ ] jail I
just did a five-year stretch I can't
even walk with my and it just it just
totally disseminated everything and then
the cops really smart hardly quietly set
to the Shoreline cribs and then it's 13
they're like you sell your rock to
whatever you want if one [ __ ] car is
broken into we're coming down on you if
one drive-by the good old days it was
just amazing so they really have crimes
back up there now though now it is but
but
what happened was when there was
chocolate when there was all of a sudden
Khan and asked said this is the number
one place to live
and the secret was out everybody started
moving in and you had these Tech Guys
then Google starts moving it yeah and
and the my property I bought a little
house for one for 350 Grand right off
Abbott right off right there it is now
worth 2.5 million we sold it way before
us I sold it for one three oh you
thought you sold it like in the last
year or two years three years ago I sold
it in 2007. my house now I'm for sale
and sold it it's and that's gross
I sold three houses oh yes yeah and the
price the way it would just it got so
crazy but that's kind of what you you
want to avoid that with Miami because
then you're gonna have just a bunch of
new people and no none of the old
Fashions no you want every time I do an
event in Florida when I was on tour and
just anything I've done there I always I
call make a point of calling you know I
mess with the crowd a lot and I always
am like where are the OG Florida people
I want them to get credit they did it
right they're Dominican yeah you know
all the Venezuelans the amount of
Hondurans that I know now that's great
and they're all good and and you know
those people they come especially the
Cubans and the Venezuelans they know
what they freaking fled they're awesome
yes I [ __ ] what makes Miami so
amazing is that Latin flavor yeah I mean
nobody's in a rush I love that [ __ ] I
love Miami I'd have a cocaine bro say
that right now I'm addicted to things
it's not a flat ass anywhere to be found
I can tell you I've been there for about
eight months now I have not seen any
cocaine I'm sure it's there yeah
would you say the best [ __ ] people it
was voted the most beautiful people
fittest city in the United also no [ __ ]
whoever made that list yeah no [ __ ] I've
been there everybody has an ass guys
gals it's fantastic some of those women
with those assets though that that
injection whatever they're doing over
there
I want to move that I can't I literally
I would be out of control I'd be like a
Tasmanian devil
yeah it's just [ __ ] career goes down
the drain my fiance now is like you're
going to wear it Miami I'm coming she
can come the baby I'm like okay no I
know you guys can come with me now if
I'm going to Spokane like I'm doing this
weekend oh yeah see you later enjoy that
she knows there's trolls up yeah right
what do you get up there like some white
people white people with bad tattoos no
sun the vitamin D deficient no weird
hairstyles
City I've seen like through the pandemic
suffered the most was Portland because
I've been Portland a million times I do
Portland the clubs downtown and I do the
meet and greets after I'm meeting all
these people and everyone I go oh you
live around here like no God no they're
like we haven't been downtown in years
man they're like it's not safe so this
cop comes I have a lot of fans who are
cops or I'm super pro blue so this cop
comes and uh he's off duty right and he
goes yeah me and my boys came to show
man big fans and he goes you're not
going out tonight right and I go ah me
and my boys we'll go to Voodoo Donuts
but I don't go to like bars or anything
else don't go and what do you mean just
don't go he goes did you go buy Voodoo
Donuts today oh yeah he goes did you see
the guy with the giant AR-15 there oh
yeah he goes is that normal to you I had
a guy with a [ __ ] semi-automatic
weapon is guarding a donut shop he goes
That's my area man it's been 15
shootings there in the past month 15
years he goes [ __ ] a donut yeah I'll be
fine though I got my big guys and I'm
thinking Portland like yeah then I have
guns he goes I live off against it I'm
telling you don't go go out like are you
[ __ ] me wow you know what and then
you're walking around just homeless and
you're like what is this it looked like
Bane took over [ __ ] Gotham well look
I saw you last time I saw you was doing
my show in Denver right and that was
about two months ago Denver not we're
not talking Portland not talking Seattle
not talking one of these crazy Northwest
cities Denver was kind of a [ __ ] the
amount of homeless encampments there was
nuts of all the cities I went to that
was the most shocking because Denver I
think is a beautiful city amazing
there's great people there they've got a
great comments
and you couldn't you know you couldn't
get them off off the because of that law
bro how about the [ __ ] uh basically
The Purge rule they pat they're gonna
pass in Chicago oh yeah incredible you
saw this yeah you guys talk about that
cash for no no no bail cash bail there's
been major business owners like we're
out man they're headed your way you know
that you know that something like
something like 60 to 80 people get shot
every weekend in Chicago usually about
it does dozen people killed we usually
cover it on Mondays on my show and
nobody cares think about that nobody
cares gang on gang violence and we'll
talk about it you're racist you're
racism Hannity used to bring it up but
it's black on black crime no so you're
right oh so that doesn't count families
those black families but my black people
are trying to do the best they can and
they have kids going to school and stuff
they have to deal with that child but
but the south side of Chicago they refer
to it is I think you know coin the term
Chiraq it's so bad I have a buddy who
stays down there we can pick them up the
Uber wouldn't even cross over to get to
South Side he goes oh we can't go in
there I'm like we can just drop We Don't
Go Near there man and then I go well
fine you can strap me off like your taxi
because taxis won't go to South Side
they got not only Jack they get killed
but that was my thing with black lives
matter I want you guys march on the
south side where people are dying every
single day no instead you're gonna March
in Bel Air they literally marched down
Melrose down Ventura where I used to
live in Sherman Oaks I had people
literally walking by my house screaming
because they figured out that I lived
there scream in that oh Trump supporter
white supremacist yelling at me I'm
walking with my husband they're
screaming at us like we're you know
literally calling us homophobes and big
integration that's when I decided so I
got the hell out of Sherman Oaks I moved
to Encino because I thought I remember I
thought if I go up the hill a little bit
they're not going to walk up a hill
these lazy [ __ ] but then but
then the whole place like that house by
the way it was a great house but not but
now trust me I didn't want to go you
were there I got pushed out they pushed
you over they pushed you but now now
Encinos riddled with uh no I know yeah
home invasions yeah yeah well wasn't it
uh was it a real housewife or something
right before I left there was like
somebody murdered an Encino and one of
them The Real Housewives she she got
tied up with her husband yeah yeah and
then uh even uh shortly after that the
head coach McVeigh of the Los Angeles
Rams was in uh vacation and his house
got broken into yeah it's at like you
know I have the ring guys have I have I
mentioned Florida since we've been here
and I'm enjoying these uh these little
anecdotes of Horror
well it's amazing what good governance
can do and it's amazing how quickly
things break down when like like
overnight how things turn into the purge
if you don't have Law and Order but
they've never answered do you think
DeSantis who I love do you think Santa's
is actually going to run so look my my
preference I think the state you live in
matters more than the country right now
I mean that in a in a somewhat like it I
don't mean that in like that the country
should just go to [ __ ] or we should no
but local politics are more effective
daily and that's what Federalism is all
about that's what the founders intended
that if you lived in a state you would
be able you'd have that experiment going
on all the time we have high taxes here
we do this let's kind of move around
right it's state by state so that's the
way it was supposed to be so on one hand
I'm like man no I just want this guy to
stay and keep solidifying the state keep
strengthening it let's get you know the
right people coming behind you all of
that stuff on the other hand the federal
thing is so freaking broken and it's so
it's coming for everybody you know one
of the things that I missed in August
they hired what was it 87 000 new
federal IRS agents that are armed to go
after people who make under 200 000
that's what the the federal government
is interested in right now but they
painted it like they were gonna go after
the big dogs they're not it's going to
affect the common creativity so the so
the only answer is to raise money from
taxpayers like I that is one way to
raise revenue but it's not Innovation
and but it's not a revenue problem and
it's not a revenue problem it's a
spending problem yes there is no amount
of money that will be enough you could
you could if you just had a [ __ ]
magic printing machine which they do
have you could print five trillion
dollars you could give it to everyone
and they would still say but we need
more money yeah because it's a spending
problem these people then the larger it
grows the more expensive so my question
for you Dave's can DeSantis fix that or
is it unfixable so I so that's like I'm
staying in Florida I know I understand
what I'm saying I'll run for president a
guy like that's not why 10 years
this isn't wired that way yeah I don't
get to his level being content with
Florida kicking I know look he loves the
state I think I I cannot speak for him
so I have no idea on this my gut feeling
would be if he honestly felt that Trump
could win if that the machine would
actually allow Trump to win and that
Biden is so compromised and and that
we're in this Jimmy Carter malaise kind
of thing I honestly think he would
probably prefer that Trump go in one
more time actually do a little bit
better in terms of breaking stuff up and
that maybe he could come behind us that
would be my guess he's got all the
justices he's got a majority
conservative Justice and all the Apple
uh yeah on the Supreme Court that's a
big deal that's that's really a big deal
I think that's more likely than not to
happen because I think Trump is going to
run just based off ego and there's a
good chance to win do you think if Trump
didn't run Trump says he's running but
if Trump didn't run then I would hope
that Santa steps up to the plate because
you don't want them going against each
other no you don't why not do president
vice president what are we doing here
no you know what it would be a bad move
for DeSantis DeSantis has has been so
clean and so good and clear that to take
number two to Trump I agree where you
end up as some kind of neutered
something it doesn't it Trump's not
going to listen though you know like
yeah but but Trump Trump's egos are out
of control he views the sentences like
you know almost like a it's a
competition thing so he wants to bury
him no there's definitely uh um you guys
do the fighting thing more than me but
I'm sure there's an analogy there of
like you don't just like work with the
number one guy you got to take him out
kind of thing like well you don't want
to take you want to take a future
Champion yeah and and neuter him break
him yeah exactly you want to protect you
want to put them for Champion yeah we
don't we don't put the young Rising
Prospect in the uh it all comes down to
Independence and DeSantis is a guy that
Independents will vote for yeah that's
really what it is but if Trump was just
like and he said the support of the
White House is a dump whatever he hates
doing it's just a New York thing so
which is hilarious but if he was just
like I'm out I don't deal with this
DeSantis he's the guy boom We're Off to
the Races that's the smart thing to do
but that's not happening well look the
other side of this thing is that Biden's
not running again he's not no no who is
so they're gonna throw Newsome so it's
probably he already announced they are
so Twisted announced today well did he
literally he basically said his exact
words were if Biden doesn't run which
obviously has to play the [ __ ] game
if Biden doesn't run I'm gonna announce
my tenancy think about what when I tell
you he is a soulless lizard person he
has destroyed everything he has touched
except made his family money so they've
got the video
no no he's got he's got a lot of wine I
get it but he was the mayor of San
Francisco if you think the way Venice
was destroyed was precipitous then what
he did to San Francisco he should be in
jail for and then he just exported it to
Cali and now this guy has the free form
no because this is what's crazy
this is the NFL analogy it would be like
having a quarterback throw 17
interceptions then someone going I like
this guy yeah let's get him on our team
and he's still throwing [ __ ]
interceptions
supervisors it's the Board of
Supervisors I have so much power the LA
border supervises five women that's the
view five women are are handling 38
billion dollars I think it's a budget of
38 billion dollars bring up the LA Board
of Supervisors you want to talk about
the where the real power sits
is that what we're doing right now with
these women if you want to talk about
all the covet policy all the things you
have these are the women who have a hell
of a lot of power so one of the windows
those women that they run La you want to
see the people who Run L.A right there
oh so that well they're handsome
very handsome he looks out of it they're
they're all but but I just said they're
handsome there's nothing wrong with that
that right there is who runs out so the
one go to the the first person you
showed with the woman in the green in
the middle so that is a Woman by the
name of Sheila cool this is a woman who
she was the deciding vote when they
decided to close outdoor restaurants
again remember we had that little moment
when things opened up people felt good
for three days and then they're like
well you know what she did you guys must
know this she was the decide fighting
vote to close outdoor eating but the
edict didn't kick in for 24 hours so
what did she do she goes eat outdoor at
her favorite restaurant in Santa Monica
Italian restaurant I forgot the name and
it's like man you you are the epitome
news about the French Laundry yeah and
then his kids being in private school
and they're playing basketball laundry
by the way now that I have all this
money
because I've never been I've never had
money well hey fellas you're gonna have
to wear a mask but yeah go ahead and go
yeah well French Master required no no
no in fact I'm trying to get in there
for my I'm I'm going up there October
6th let me let me see what I can do I I
would love that you've got a lot of
power just buy me a table there but one
thing the one thing about his own group
yeah yeah and it's very interesting
Tom Arnold I love my mother
but the fact of the matter is that if if
women like that don't have a balance of
some male energy or some other energy in
there what my mother wouldn't let me my
mother would like me to be in a golden
cage my mother would like me to not go
out of the house and stay in a golden
kiss the faucy and you have to be safe
yes and you know and I'm going to say
this and I'm going to get [ __ ] for this
but in fact long covet
um the vast majority of cases I don't
know if you guys know this but the vast
majority of cases of long covet
are middle-aged yeah
probably middle-aged liberal women
because they do tend to have motorcycles
usually middle-aged
white for the most part educated crazy
yeah you forgot crazy yeah they suffer
from things like fibromyalgia I'm not
saying that's not a real disease but but
in the the numbers are very interesting
right that they sway toward you know
chronic fatigue and long covet so there
might be send one that one almost freaks
me out yes there might be some hysteria
there yeah if we don't have somebody
telling my mom Mom I love you you want
to take care of the world but Mom you
can't be the nurse of the world I'm
going to play football or I'm going to
do the sport and I don't give a [ __ ] and
if I die I'm gonna [ __ ] die you don't
want anybody passing laws where if they
get a paper cut they're [ __ ] you need
a mix like we don't want that you need a
mix again I just want to I can't
remember did I mention Florida
you guys are go pull up the picture one
more time you guys are burned by this
five crazy yeah yeah those are your
women these women have no these women
have power over a lot of power these
women whether you guys
I'll do a philosophical one for you
because I know you like that sort of
thing if they mean well so let's grant
them the meanwhile right yes okay well a
the road to hell is paid with good
intentions fine yes but if you keep
doing it wrong and the results of all of
those things even if you mean well the
entire time are destroying other
people's lives at what point does a guy
like you who is trying I get what you're
trying to do and I used to do it yeah at
what point do you go it simply does not
matter anymore because what's the
definition of crazy I agree what's the
definition of crazy saying that I I
think it's out that we need to get them
out of there yeah and that we have that
if you want to change politics start
there if you actually want to change the
way this this city itself or the cities
like San Francisco and and you know San
Francisco the city council they don't
even have a Democrat they're all they're
all they're all socialists
they're all full-on comments yeah yeah
and you don't have a Democrat yeah so if
you actually are serious about changing
the landscape in your city you gotta you
gotta attack where it matters you got to
take out that those are the needs so so
is there any evidence and this was part
of my calculation in leaving is there
any evidence that anything is turning
around
they would say and gavinism would say
and he will say we have a tax Surplus
guys I mean that we're flush we're
making money and then they'll point to a
whole bunch of stats now of course there
are lies damn lies and statistics you
can play with Statistics but if you look
at the amount of money they were making
off there's still the legacy of Silicon
Valley there's still that crazy tax bill
so they're going to be like what right
what and you have to know how to fight
them you have to know exactly what their
talking points are going to be and be
ready for that yeah but so you still
have the Surplus surplus of money yeah
and then they want to defund the police
well crimes number so but again let me
let me go through this so it's not
Insanity so so you have maybe it has
been working on him you're coming to
Florida
you didn't see it I bought my ticket I'm
saying that Gavin Newsom is a simple I'm
your new name
I'm your new neighbor dude yeah I want
in wait I'll be the pool boy bro just
show me where the money is you're not
coming over to rumble brother I gotta
make sure rats don't chew it up
I gotta I got a dust I'm just dusting
the stacks I'm busting Stacks but but
I'm saying that Newsom is a symptom of a
democratic super majority yes in [ __ ]
Sacramento use their mouth how the [ __ ]
did that happen how did we get literally
when I remember when Arnold
Schwarzenegger they had these they had
these
Republicans he's going to take over
California and they had these they had
these experienced reporters political
report words California guys have been
there for 40 years and every one of them
went it was on NPR they all went no no I
know there's a lot of enthusiasm it's
going to be very difficult for him to
get anything done meaning he's not and
then I talked to Schwarzenegger then I
had dinner with him yeah John Leguizamo
and I were doing this movie and he goes
my friends come and you'll like it
Schwarzenegger shows up with an
assistant I'm like oh I forget to hang
with him yeah and I just read a book on
California politics by Michael Lewis uh
called Boomerang he wrote The Big Short
and all this and so I had I could I was
able to talk to him Schwarzenegger said
to me he was talking about how there was
a water shortage and he said all he said
was he goes I know how we do this
there's a water shortage but I'm looking
at the numbers the farmers over here
don't need that much water almonds just
get them to give us the water just get
them to take less water yeah just you
know and we'll take that water and bring
it over here no big deal you're not
using it you're not using that water so
let's just bring it over here easy
terminated Senators came in the centers
who were Republicans they go listen
you don't know how it works we can't go
to our district and say you don't get
more water I won't get reelected they'll
use that against me yeah so but it's a
good idea so what we're going to do is
you're going to make a speech
and you're going to say that you're
going to say that and you're going to
get credit for that and then we're going
to get behind you and then we're going
to do nothing yes and then what we're
going to do is we're not going to do
that because we're going to have to kind
of we're going to stall it that's how
politics works for him and he said the
biggest thing the hardest thing was how
little power he actually had yeah what a
[ __ ] it was to get anything done
well that was when I was campaigning
with Larry Elder for the recall and
Larry's a good buddy of mine that his
main concern was you know okay even if
this miracle happens there is almost
nothing I can do you know you can do a
few things by executive order but that
he's a Libertarian not with a democratic
Superman by the way you know there is a
place with water it's called Florida
have you guys ever been there
everywhere sometimes too much water to
be honest I know all about it B I gotta
catch a flight dude all right the
flight's at 3 30. Dave Rubin you're
you're always awesome man I just love
seeing you you're my buddy this is very
exciting because I feel like I did work
here with you guys we're really with him
though you guys should come too I mean
everybody should come the whole school
uh you know can I tell you it was one of
the nicest moments of all the guests
that I ever had so I've Loved loved
loved him since his first day super
special I think you remember the young
comic specials on HBO like 1983. he did
the one that Seinfeld made his TV debut
also he crushed it people remember
Seinfeld from that he freaking cried I
have a mother she calls me up is
everything wrong
but at the end of the you know he's a
big germaphobe that's the thing on curb
that he's always doing with Larry at the
end this is in my house I walk him out
to the car and uh and I said Richard I
just want to thank you I I just I've
loved you forever and he's a big
germaphobe he doesn't like touching
people and he went like this
you got it kid oh and I was like I was
like
that's a big deal pretty good you
touched my face and now I touch your
face I got some now I've been ready
now Brian's gonna vote for a disaster
yeah I didn't need to touch his face
he's going to his 98 year old
grandmother's funeral
where that wear that green suit uh what
a pleasure man I love you buddy now I'm
gonna go bang up Mark you guys warm me
up now I'm feeling now you're ready to
go you know we give you a little pep you
ready for some more tell them we'd love
to have Dave you gave me pep I'll be in
Boston next Thursday Friday Saturday in
Boston laugh Boston that is almost sold
out Thursday Friday Saturday then San
Jose is October 13th through the 15th
San Jose Improv Salt Lake City Wise Guys
October 20th through 22nd then Calgary
they just lifted the mask and mandates
in Canada so October 27th and 28th
rooftop Calgary downtown tickets at
thickboy.com I'm gonna be in Spokane
Washington starting tomorrow uh
September 22nd uh Friday Saturday then
Tacoma Washington Tacoma Comedy Club
September 29th October I mean September
30th October 1. Bridgeport Connecticut
Stress Factory October 13 14 15.
Schaumburg Illinois Chicago improv and
uh my special uh man tears is on YouTube
check it out Dave we love you man keep
crushing it I'll be counting my money
tomorrow
Dave Rubin